[Musik]
zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
reichen die korona maßnahmen tja das ist
heute unser thema und das ist auch das
zentrale thema auf den bund länder
beratungen die heute wieder stattfinden
noch stattfinden zum ersten mal
allerdings unter der leitung des
frischgebackenen bundeskanzlers olaf
scholz wir sprechen später in der
sendung mit dem modell ihrer und
epidemiologen dirk brockmann und mit der
präsidentin der deutschen gesellschaft
für immunologie mit professor christine
falk zunächst aber schalten wir nach
berlin zu meiner kollegin nicole
diekmann da steht sie in nicole also das
erste bund länder treffen wir haben
gesagt mit dem neuen kanzler unter
seiner leitung was ist da denn heute zu
erwarten stellte ein großer wurf bevor
nein das muss ich gleich zu beginn sagen
also sollte diese erwartungshaltung bei
jemandem bei jemandem bestehen wir
erinnern uns letzte woche gab es zwei
treffen das erste am dienstag das nicht
mpk heißen durfte und nicht so hieß weil
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
präsidentin der länder immer zu diesen
treffen einladen das war in diesem fall
nicht der fall sondern das war eine
vorbesprechung weil man nämlich wiederum
letzten donnerstag das war dann
tatsächlich eine mpk einen großen wurf
präsentieren wollte und vorher schon mal
sondieren ob man da überhaupt so weit
zusammen kommen könnte heute stehen
mehrere themen auf der tagesordnung
nicht nur coroner natürlich auch corinna
alles andere wäre natürlich auch sehr
überraschend aber unter anderem auch die
lage an der grenze perus
werden wird heute besprochen oder auch
der umgang mit messenger diensten zum
beispiel telegramm das ja auch da haben
wir es wieder im zusammenhang mit corona
vor allem in den letzten tagen und
wochen immer mehr ins öffentliche
bewusstsein gerückt ist als großes
problem dazu wollte sich gleich noch
fragen aber wir bleiben zunächst noch
mal beim thema corona weil das ja auch
das thema ist womit wir uns heute
schwerpunktmäßig
beschäftigen das infektionsschutzgesetz
das ist ja gleich mehrfach geändert
worden in den letzten tagen wochen muss
man sagen ist denn jetzt klar dass alle
beteiligten mit der aktuell vorliegenden
version sozusagen zufrieden sind ist da
noch mal wie widerspruch zu erwarten
wird daran noch einmal gerüttelt werden
müssen oder wie ist da aktuell die lage
also das wäre auch ein ding wir haben
diese woche schon eine sitzung im
bundestag gehabt erster lesung nächste
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
und haben morgen zweite und dritte
lesung wieder im bundestag und
anschließend eine sondersitzung des
bundesrates einziger tagesordnungspunkt
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
das zeigt also die lage ist höchst
dramatisch man peitscht dieses ding
jetzt durch um es mal ganz salopp zu
sagen weil man erkannt hatte dass man in
der vorherigen version die noch gar
nicht so alt war doch zu viel raum
gelassen hatte und zwar für corona für
die ausweitung des virus denn die zahlen
sind nach wie vor sehr hoch auch heute
haben die intensivmediziner erneut alarm
geschlagen und sagen wir müssen die
inzidenz unter 200 drücken um weiter
einigermaßen klar zu kommen auch mit
rubicon vor augen von dieser variante
wissen wir ja alle noch nicht so genau
was sie eigentlich bedeutet ob die
verläufe schlimmer sind wenn man sich
mit dieser variante ansteckt oder nicht
aber im moment herrscht ja delta vor und
eine inzidenz von 200 wie sie die
intensivmediziner
anmahnen als höchstmarke davon ist man
hier noch weit entfernt wir sind ja noch
bei instanzen die doppelt so hoch sind
ich gebe hiermit noch mal gerne die
aufforderung an unser publikum weiter
uns gerne mit fragen und kommentaren zu
versorgen
eine frage von alwin handschellen über
youtube zu erreicht uns ernst gemeinte
frage wie will man gewährleisten dass im
öpnv audi 3g regeln kontrolliert werden
ich wurde nur einmal am tag
zweimal kontrolliert sonst nie sehe
genug leute die ohne maske fahren
ärgerlich also das ist jetzt die frage
an die politik natürlich im weitesten
sinne wie will man das gewährleisten
auch darüber ist ja wahrscheinlich in
den letzten tagen auch in berlin
mehrfach diskutiert worden wie will man
solche regeln in der praxis durchsetzen
also ehrlich gesagt finde ich zwei
punkte interessant an dieser zuschrift
nämlich dass er zweimal an einem tag
kontrolliert worden ist und dass
zweitens immer noch leute gibt die
trotzdem keine maske tragen
zweimal am tag war spricht deshalb weil
das relativ viel ist nach allem was man
sonst so hört aber natürlich war auch
bei den mahnungen auch in der
vergangenen woche dass die kontrollen
schärfer werden müssen dass die mehr
werden müssen dass die flächendeckender
werden müssen und regelmäßiger auch
immer der einsatz der dann noch angefügt
wurde der wir können eigentlich nur
stichprobenartig überprüfen aber genau
das müssen wir tun also das heißt es ist
jetzt nicht so dass
jemand wenn ich zum beispiel in den zug
steige oder in die u-bahn dass da zum
beispiel oben das ist ja überall
unterschiedlich geregelt wobei am
eingang leute stehen und kontrollieren
von jedem der da einsteigt ob die drei
gericke da greift oder nicht das ist
überhaupt nicht zu gewährleisten oder
eben unten dann am bahnsteig sondern es
sind stichproben
genau und darauf wird es hinauslaufen so
wird es wohl auch bleiben anders geht es
im grunde gar nicht anderer punkt den
die fans schon angesprochen hast es gibt
also gemeinsame anstrengungen von bund
und ländern im kampf gegen hass und
hetze auf den social media plattformen
auch das natürlich jetzt vor dem
hintergrund von corona und allen
möglichen versammlungen die sich gerade
in den östlichen bundesländern nicht nur
dort aber eben insbesondere da in den
letzten tagen doch gezeigt haben ein
wichtiger punkt was ist da geplant ja es
gibt oder fange ich manchmal immer
anders an es geht in erster linie auch
wenn das so nicht drin steht in der
beschlussvorlage über der mann da gerade
im in dieser konferenz brütet verein
dingen und telegramm telegram ist ja in
den vergangenen tagen und wochen sehr
oft genannt worden zum einen weil es als
ein zentrales instrument der vernetzung
der sogenannten querdenker szene dient
die sich ja zunehmend radikalisiert
telegramm soll eine rolle gespielt haben
bei der verabredung zum fackel aufmarsch
vor dem
wohnhaus dem privathaus einer
sächsischen ministerin am vergangenen
wochenende und telegramm hat eine
sonderstellung telegram dient bzw gilt
nicht als klassische
plattform als klassisches soziales
medium wie zum beispiel facebook oder
twitter clm ist streng genommen ein
messenger dienst kann aber auch quasi
benutzt werden wie ein wie eine soziale
plattform und es gibt ja ein äquivalent
es gibt ja bei sap das ist verbreiteter
im gegensatz zu whatsapp der erste große
unterschied ist dass whatsapp aus
ähnlichen erfahrungen wie sie gerade
telegramm macht
einschränkungen mittlerweile vorne das
heißt nachrichten können nur noch an
eine begrenzte zahl von menschen weiter
verbreitet werden und das erklärte ziel
ist damit dass informationen fake news
einzudämmen so telegramm macht das nicht
bis zu 200.000 leute können so einem
kanal folgen und die nachrichten die
dort gepostet werden erreichen dann
diese abonnenten dass das erst der
zweite grundlegende unterschied zwischen
whatsapp das ja zu facebook gehört und
telegramm ist das whatsapp wenn auch in
einem noch sehr ausbaufähigen maße mit
den sicherheitsbehörden kooperiert
telegramm hingegen telegramm wird
explizit damit auf seiner seite dass es
das nicht tut das ist nicht mit
sicherheits behörden kooperiert das
heißt wenn leute wie attila hildmann ja
zum beispiel schon rausgeflogen ist bei
instagram
der ja mittlerweile per strafbefehl
gesucht wird und sich ins ausland
abgesetzt hat wenn attila hildmann
seine potenziell
gesetzeswidrigen postings bei telegramme
veröffentlicht dann hat telegramm kein
interesse daran mit den justizbehörden
hier in deutschland zum beispiel
zusammenzuarbeiten im gegenteil
kilogramm versteht sich selber als eine
plattform als ein messenger dienst der
genau solchen leuten wie hält man die
anderen plattform zu krass waren eine
heimat so und nun sagt man die
innenminister haben sich vergangene
woche getroffen die innenminister der
länder und sagen wir müssen telegramm
unter das sogenannte netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz auch zehn das
sogenannte netz dg das eben dafür da ist
den plattformen in die pflicht zu nehmen
das heißt da endlich einen riegel
vorzuschieben dass da so viel gehetzt
beleidigt bedroht wird und dass
informationen eben gerade in der korona
käse sieht man das ja verbreitet werden
das ist an sich ein guter ansatz aber
das netz funktioniert halt auch nur halb
gut deswegen die
dass die aufmerksamkeit ist mittlerweile
da das bewusstsein ist da wie gefährlich
diese plattform inklusive messenger
diensten sind aber die handhabe ist noch
steht noch sehr am anfang
dankeschön für den moment wir warten
natürlich immer noch auf die
pressekonferenz dass nach diesem bund
länder treffen und gucken einstweilen
noch mal auf die stuhlreihe aber wir
sehen dass sich da noch nichts getan hat
und sprechen natürlich mit nicole
diekmann dann auch weiter sobald ist da
neue
äußerungen gibt dann wird uns nicht
weiterhelfen die sachen einzuordnen
wollen jetzt aber weiter machen ja noch
mal mit einem blick auf die aktuelle
situation in deutschland was die korona
maßnahmen eigentlich angeht wie sind wir
momentan auf die pandemie eingestellt
einzelheiten dazu von johanna sagt
meister
bilder die man in deutschland vermeiden
wollte intensivpatienten werden
ausgeflogen von sachsen nach nordrhein
westfalen
die luftwaffe hilft seit ende wenn bei
der pandemie bekämpfung es ging nicht
mehr ohne sie denn die vierte welle
trifft deutschland besonders hart
krankenhäuser sind vielerorts am rande
ihrer belastung das rkw melde täglich
hunderte coruna tote auch wenn
expertinnen schon im september vor der
vierten welle warnten wächst die
scheinbar ungebremst weiter erreicht
ende november immer neue höchststände
ursachen dafür gibt es viele die
ansteckende delta variante den
nachlassenden impfschutz und die hohe
zahl an ungeimpften aber auch fehlende
corona schutzmaßnahmen spielen eine
rolle das sollte sich am zweiten
dezember ändern bund und länder einigen
sich auf weitreichende maßnahmen
sie treffen besonders ungeimpfte
menschen für sie gelten ab sofort
strengere kontakt beschränkungen im
privaten bereich auch in den
einzelhandel kommen sie nicht mehr rein
hier gilt nun zweig ausgenommen sind
alleine geschäfte des täglichen bedarfs
auch für kultur und freizeit
veranstaltungen gilt zweig oder sogar
zweig plus in sportarenen müssen künftig
viele plätze leer bleiben und an schulen
gilt eine massen pflicht für alle
klassenstufen eine sinnvolle regel zeigt
eine aktuelle studie des
max-planck-instituts
werden ffp zwei masten richtig getragen
schützen sie fast 100 prozent vor einer
infektion bei op masken liegt das
infektionsrisiko noch bei 10 prozent
weil jetzt vielerorts zweig plus geld
sind corona schnelltests auch für
geimpfte wieder zur routine geworden
eine studie des paul ehrlich instituts
zeigt aber ihre qualität ist teils
extrem unterschiedlich viele erkennen
selbst bei einer sehr hohen viruslast
die infektion nicht in die ferne die
beschlossenen maßnahmen wirken sie vor
allem die intensivstationen entlasten
zeigt sich erst in ein paar wochen es
ist nicht auszuschließen dass weitere
verschärfungen nötig sein werden
und darüber sprechen wir mit einem der
führenden corona modellierer eben
deutschland der sich bestens auskennt
also mit zahlen daten und
verbreitungswegen des virus herzlich
willkommen professor dirk brockmann
hallo hallo wir haben es gerade schon
ein paar beispiele gesehen für maßnahmen
die derzeit in kraft sind wie es ihrer
einschätzung die sind wir denn aktuell
gestellt was die anti coroner maßnahmen
angeht na ja das kam er in dem beitrag
heraus dass zb masken den schulen sehr
wichtiges element sind wir gucken uns
insbesondere dass kontakt verhalten an
wie es sich verändert im verlauf der
pandemie und da sehen wir tatsächlich
dass es jetzt seit einigen einiger zeit
auch rückgänge gibt in dem kontakt
verhalten also insbesondere in der
sogenannten kontakt variabilität das
heißt menschen treffen sich weniger
häufig in großen gruppen das sieht man
insbesondere wenn man wochenende und
werktags vergleich da war noch vor
einiger zeit eine große schere weil halt
menschen wieder sich in großen gruppen
getroffen haben das ist jetzt rückläufig
insbesondere in sachsen beispielsweise
wo das sehr stark jetzt runter gegangen
ist und teile dieser dieses abfalls
sehen wir auch im zusammenhang mit den
maßnahmen die ergriffen worden sind der
grünen gesundheitsexperte janosch dahmen
er hat noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass
bei neun von zehn infektions vorgängen
ungeimpfte beteiligt sind
deckt sich das mit ihren erkenntnissen
und wenn ja was sollte daraus dann
folgen auch für das bund länder treffen
heute ja da hat ja noch damen sich auf
eine studie bezogen die wir selbst
gemacht haben die also aus unserer
arbeitsgruppe kommt und das ist
tatsächlich so wenn man das sagen wir
mal den er wehrte er ein wichtiger wert
ist der muss ja unter 1 sehen wenn man
den aufteilt infektionsgeschehen unter
den geimpften oder unter den ungeimpften
da gibt es sozusagen vier kombinationen
weil die sich alle gegenseitig anstecken
können das haben wir dann berechnet das
hat benjamin mayer in einer
arbeitsgruppe gemacht da zeigt sich dass
quasi 80 bis 90 prozent der ansteckung
es ereignisse die stadt finden immer
eine ungeimpfte person beteiligt ist
entweder als eine person die die
ansteckt aber eben auch als eine person
die angesteckt wird und das obwohl die
der teil der bevölkerung ja kleiner ist
als etwa bei 30 prozent liegt das heißt
impfen schützt nicht nur sehr gut gegen
einen schweren krankheitsverlauf
sondern es mindert auch den
das infektionsgeschehen und das wollten
wir halt in dieser studie zeigen und so
ungefähr verhält sich das also zwischen
80 und 90 prozent der ansteckungen da
ist immer entweder eine ungeimpfte
person als angesteckte als anstecken
oder beides beteiligt und was folgt
daraus also das bedeutet dass man die
ungeimpften noch stärker isolieren
müsste oder wie habe ich das dann zu
verstehen naja das ist erst mal eine
ganz nüchterne erkenntnis und jetzt muss
man daraus schlussfolgerungen ziehen
eine ist natürlich dass mehr geimpft
werden muss damit das so zusammen
mittelfristigen starken effekt hat
gerade auch im licht der nikon variante
die vor der tür steht also ein stichwort
booster impfung also impfschutz
möglichst hoch zu ziehen in der gesamten
bevölkerung ist halt ein ganz wichtiges
element
aber die wichtige aussage dieser studie
ist halt dass das auch mit dem
infektionsgeschehen eben etwas zu tun
hat dass wir eine relativ also eine
vergleichsweise geringe im kot haben
wenn wir das vergleich mit portugal oder
anderen ländern das ist ein wesentliches
element auch für das infektionsgeschehen
und natürlich muss man somit dann halt
auch die die kontakte zwischen zwischen
allen endlich reduzieren damit
gewährleistet ist dass auch ungeimpfte
sich nicht anstecken oder anstecken
eine maßnahme die momentan ganz oben
steht omikron sie haben es angesprochen
macht sorgen verbreitet sich auch sehr
schnell zum beispiel auch in
großbritannien dazu eine einschätzung zu
der verbreitung der möglichen in
deutschland nochmal von karl lauterbach
dem neuen gesundheitsminister
die ergebnisse die wir heute gesehen
haben sind nicht ganz überraschend zu
bestätigen leider negative ergebnisse
die wir schon kannten somit ist die neue
realität die die impfung ist nur
abgeschlossen wenn man drei mal geimpft
wurde also der bürger muss quasi
verstehen haben wir früher immer gesagt
zwei impfungen erste und zweite impfung
das ist ein kompletter impfschutz und
dann kommt später eine besserung um den
impfstoff zu impfschutz zu verlängern
wir müssen das jetzt so sehen man
braucht drei impfungen überhaupt vor
oregon einigermaßen geschützt zu sein
sonst kommen wir hier nicht klar und wir
müssen natürlich dafür sorgen dass auch
ich kann so spät kommt wie möglich ja
und nikon sollte so spät kommen wie
möglich also uns möglichst spät treffen
als nation jetzt gucken wir mal gerade
hier auf dieser seite european centre
for disease prevention and control da
sind nämlich ein paar daten aufgeführt
und da ist eben auch schon zumindest mal
auf gezählt wie viele registrierte fälle
ist bislang gibt zum beispiel in der eu
mit 274 das klingt jetzt erstmal noch
nicht so viel zumal alleine in dänemark
nach einer allerdings etwas anderen
berechnungsmethode 2 161 fälle schon
aufgetaucht sind das ist jetzt in dieser
statistik etwas irreführend müssten
eigentlich ein paar weniger sein also
insgesamt noch recht wenig in dänemark
relativ viel in deutschland 15
nachgewiesene wir haben aber hinweise
dafür dass es da auch hoch geht jetzt in
den nächsten stunden
professor borgmann was halten sie von
omikron und vor allem was glauben sie
wie schnell wird sich diese variante
verbreiten also was halten sie davon
epidemiologische hinsicht naja also was
wir beobachten ist das was herr
lauterbach gerade gesagt hat dass stetig
sich eine befürchtung nämlich dass diese
variante offenbar ansteckender ist als
die delta variante mit der wir uns
gerade beschäftigen wir sehen das in
großbritannien das ist immer ganz
typische neue varianten auftauchen das
war beim wildtyp so als das ursprünglich
aus china heraus über den globus
verteilt hat dann haben wir ja die
ersten fälle gesehen und man hat das so
gezählt das sind 15 16 vielleicht 20 und
dann kam es dann so in die hunderte
bereiche und irgendwann hat man so eine
schwelle erreicht wo das dann sozusagen
so viele fälle sind dass es sich von
alleine halt dann in so ein
exponentielles wachstum begibt und in
großbritannien haben wir jetzt einige
hundert fälle in dänemark auch das heißt
man kann davon ausgehen dass das nicht
mehr reine sozusagen schwankungen sind
entweder in der messung oder dass es
reine importe sind sondern man kann
davon ausgehen dass diese variante sich
schnell verbreiten wird und so ähnlich
wie delta auch die alpha variante sehr
schnell verdrängt hat das omikron dass
das gleiche auch mit der delta variante
tut das ist jedenfalls ein szenario was
man berechnen kann wenn man so grob
geschätzt wie unterschiedlich stark
omikron und delta sich ausbreitenden der
bevölkerung dann kann man das so grob
schätzen und dann kann man so in etwa
sagen dass oder man kann prognostizieren
dass ein wahrscheinliches szenario ist
dass oerlikon quasi delta verdrängt weil
das hand stecken da ist
und in diesem zusammenhang fragt uns im
melanie xbox über youtube können wir
denn eine nährwert von 0,7 mit den
aktuellen maßnahmen erreichen auch vor
dem hintergrund der neuen omikron
variante wie würden sie das einschätzen
das ist super frage also wir haben
verschiedene berechnungen gemacht wie
man sozusagen den herr wert deutlich
unter 1 also zum beispiel auf 0,7 drückt
man kann leider was die kontakt
beschränkung angeht mit denen wir uns
beschäftigen nur schlecht abschätzen wie
stark wird sagen der wert unter diesen
wo darunter gedrückt wird durch durch
das was wir in der kontakt reduktion
sehen es ist relativ viel versprechend
dass kontakte nicht mehr in großen
gruppen stattfinden oder deutlich
weniger weil das ein substanzieller
anteil des erwerbs ist aber das gehört
halt auch dazu man muss halt wenn man
dieses ziel nur 0,7 erreichen will oder
noch besser noch weniger jetzt mal ohne
omikron gerechnet dann muss man halt
alles machen fasst man was man machen
kann also masken in schulen kontakte
reduzieren und natürlich postern und
die wird sagen die impflücken schließen
dann gucken wir gerade vielleicht noch
mal auf ein paar zahlen die wir in einer
anderen form ihnen vielleicht noch mal
gerade mit geben können da geht es um
die hospitalisierung rate auch in
deutschland und das ist ganz interessant
das findet man auf unserer eigenen seite
heute de da gibt es also ein
auseinanderfallen von tatsächlicher und
auch von geschätzter hospitalisierung
incidents man sieht dass hier ganz schön
da ist die geschätzte bei 12 die
tatsächlich gemessene bei 6 aber da gibt
es eben große unterschiede weil man
davon ausgeht dass viele krankenhäuser
aber auch viele ämter die das
weitergeben momentan sehr überlastet
sind dann kann man hier vielleicht
gerade noch mal schauen auch auf zahlen
die uns aus den einzelnen bundesländern
erreichen insgesamt der schnitt in
deutschland 5,75 in thüringen bei 18,82
sachsen 9,93 vielleicht da auch gerade
noch mal die frage an sie als mensch der
viel mit zahlen hantiert wie verlässlich
sind solche daten ihrer meinung nach im
moment oder geben die welchen ausschuss
können die im moment geben na ja also
das ist natürlich ein problem dass wenn
wenn das system so an die grenzen fährt
wenn man dann keine verlässlichen zahlen
hat das gilt ja auch für die instanz ist
das jedenfalls ein szenario dass diese
zahlen die dann gemeldet werden nicht
mehr nicht mehr verlässlich sind und
dann kann es halt sein dass zum beispiel
eine plateau bildung in der instanz eine
fehlinterpretation ist oder eine teil
fehlinterpretation weil weil so wenig
fälle gemeldet sind das wäre natürlich
fatal und deshalb ist es so wichtig dass
diese zahlen verlässlich sind aber wir
müssen natürlich so als modell ihrer und
leute die versuchen aus den aus den
kurven
erkenntnisse zu ziehen mit den zahlen
arbeiten die wir haben manchmal kann man
sozusagen durch methodische tricks auch
zeigen dass da irgendwie eine lücke da
sein muss weil sich irgendwelche
veränderungen einfach nicht mit dem
decken was man was man weiß aber
natürlich ist sozusagen die basis auf
der wir wir handeln müssen deshalb
gucken wir ja auch zum beispiel die
mobilität an oder die
kontakthäufigkeit jeden tag damit wir
sozusagen
verhaltens marca sehen die unabhängig
sind von incidents hospitalisierung
since i denn czk und sehr schnell
funktionieren aber auch eben nur als ein
element in diesem ganzen blumenstrauß
von daten die man sich anguckt weil sie
gerade die mobilität angesprochen haben
die sich natürlich auch untersuchen das
ist ja nun durchaus jetzt auch in diesem
monat wieder ein interessantes thema die
feiertage weihnachten steht vor der tür
quasi auch da setzt normalerweise so
eine art doch reiseverkehr 1
wie sehen sie das was würden sie
momentan den leuten mit an die hand
geben als empfehlung wie soll man sich
da verhalten naja also mobilität ist ja
erst mal so ein indirekter
nun in direktes maß für kontakte ganz
einfach weil wenn man unterwegs ist von
a nach b in den meisten fällen
jedenfalls am zielort mit leuten in
irgendeiner weise
zusammen trifft das kann natürlich mit
maske sein sollte auch mit maske seien
in den meisten fällen
habe es ist natürlich in der tat so wenn
jetzt die wenn wir sehen dass die
mobilität besonders stark ansteigt wie
zb im sommer weil halt viele menschen in
deutschland urlaub gemacht haben nicht
ins ausland geflogen sind da war
sozusagen überproportional viele
unterwegs an der ostsee und auch in der
nordsee und in den in den feriengebieten
aber wenn wir jetzt sehen dass
weihnachten deutlich mehr unterwegs ist
bedeutet das auch deutlich mehr kontakte
in der summe aber
man muss dabei bedenken dass es
tatsächlich bei der effektivsten kontakt
reduktion darum geht treffen in großen
gruppen zu vermeiden damit nicht eine
person oder vielleicht zwei
80 90 100 menschen anstecken können
insbesondere halt mit delta oder dann
auch mit omikron der effektivste weg und
das ist ein teil davon ist tatsächlich
diese großen gruppen zu reduzieren und
man kann sich dann halt um weihnachten
fragen feiere ich mit zehn menschen oder
mit fünf menschen und er kann dann halt
jede person auch entscheiden das
vielleicht zu verkleinern weil
wenn sie eine gruppe um die hälfte
verkleinern also sagen wir mal von zehn
auf fünf dann können da nur noch ein
viertel der kontakte stattfinden und das
ist halt eine substanzielle reduktion
das heißt diese gruppengrößen reduktion
des eines der effektivsten elemente in
der kontakt reduktion sohn also im
prinzip je weniger leute sich treffen
unterm weihnachtsbaum beziehungsweise an
der tafel am abend umso besser ist es
eigentlich noch eine frage die uns
erreicht von andreas w über youtube im
sportverein sehen wir immer die gleichen
leute ähnlich wie im beruf trotzdem
gelten in bayern 2 g + auflagen wie in
den kinos wo viel publikumsverkehr ist
ist das sinnvoll also die frage ist muss
man auch
in anderen bereichen außer jetzt im kino
dieses 2+ hinnehmen absolut das ist
deshalb sinnvoll es stimmt zwar dass man
vorwiegend dann mit menschen zu tun hat
die man halt täglich trifft aber es kann
ja auch sein dass man man hat ja nicht
ausschließlich mit diesen menschen zu
tun sondern ab und zu ist dann auch mal
eine person sich das virus halt ein
fängt irgendwo
und dann in diese gruppen rein trägt und
weil man zum beispiel täglich oder
wöchentlich mit diesen leuten dann mit
den gleichen leuten sich trifft das dann
relativ wahrscheinlich dass dann eine
recht großen gruppe so ein super
spreading ereignis stattfinden kann
insofern ist es immer gut wir dürfen
auch nicht immer fragen was notwendig
ist sondern wir müssen gegebenenfalls
mehr tun damit halt der wert deutlich
unter 1 hängt und die fallzahlen das
hatten wir ja auch ein beitrag gehört so
niedrig werden dass dann die kliniken
und die intensivstation
besser klar kommen und dass wir wollen
ja schnell dahinkommen wir wollen jetzt
nicht ein halbes jahr warten dass
sozusagen die kurve ganz langsam runter
geht das so zu sagen kumulativ dass das
leid was da entsteht natürlich viel
größer wenn wir sind schnell runter und
wir könnten sollten uns mal die frage
stellen was können wir machen und nicht
was können wir lassen nicolai ki fragt
uns über youtube bzw fragt sie ganz
konkret weil er sich offenbar sehr für
ihre arbeit interessiert mit welchen
daten wird denn eigentlich modelliert so
ganz allgemein ich könnte mir vorstellen
da kommen die unterschiedlichsten zur
anwendung ja das stimmt also das ist da
gibt es ganz viele verschiedene daten
und das hängt auch ein bisschen ab von
dem modell das man gerade entwirft oder
dass man anwendet also es gibt modelle
die arbeiten prognostisch die versuchen
halt vorhersagen zu machen szenarien in
der zukunft dann gibt es modelle die
sind eher so dafür da um die jetzige
situation besser einzuschätzen und dann
gibt es einfach auch datenanalyse das
heißt sozusagen in diesem bereich
digitale epidemiologie wo man versucht
neue datenquellen
anzuschauen die man halt die wie sehr
verlässlich sind und die man täglich
aktualisiert bekommt und die in jan de
meldet system dranhängen stichwort
mobilität oder kontakte dass man halt
schnell sich ein bild machen
kann von der jetzigen situation um dann
zu wissen was dann zum beispiel mit der
incidents passiert oder dann latent
danach mit mit dem haus
spezialisierungen also darum geht es im
wesentlichen aber tendenziell guckt man
je nach modell was man welche fragen man
mit dem modell beantworten will muss man
dann die daten suchen die man dafür
braucht das sind oft der
infektionsstatus manchmal sind das auch
so über der impfstudie die gemacht
worden ist dann muss man dann abschätzen
wie viele kontakte zwischen
verschiedenen altersgruppen stattfinden
und solche details kommen dann damit
rein damit dass sozusagen immer genauer
wird die vorhersage machen sie sich
eigentlich sorgen vor den neuen
varianten also dass wenn jetzt was
auftaucht wie omikron sagen sie sich
dann ja gut das wird nicht die letzte
sein da werden dann auf weitere folgen
sind sie da besorgt was dieses thema
angeht ja also der ich bin ja sozusagen
zwei leute ich bin einmal der
wissenschaftler und einmal die person
und
wissenschaftlich dass er nüchtern zu
betrachten und auch aber in der
wissenschaft gibt es besorgnis weil man
dann abschätzen kann was das dynamisch
für die pandemie bedeutet und das hatten
wir ja eben auch schon besprochen dass
das es nicht unwahrscheinlich ist dass
omikron sich sehr schnell durchsetzt und
das auch die impfstoffe anders wirken
bei uns herum gekommen dass man
sozusagen im kopf umschalten muss wie
karl lauterbach sagte dass die
vollständige impfung keine
zweifach-impfung sondern eine dreifach
impfung wir müssen uns halt immer
anpassen wir müssen auch schneller
werden als das video wir müssen uns
jetzt einfach schneller bewegen als das
virus an uns hand passen schneller
reagieren und
dann ja das habe ich aber auch schon vor
monaten gesagt dass diese pandemie immer
wieder überraschungen hat jetzt das
mikro es kann auch sein dass es noch
varianten gibt und wir in eine routine
kommen werden der impfstoffe angepasst
werden es ist ja auch ein segen dass wir
die männer impfstoffe haben die relativ
ich will nicht sagen einfach aber doch
einfach her angepasst werden können an
neue virusvarianten das ist ja im
prinzip ein segen und es wäre natürlich
auch ein segen wenn das welt mit
geschirr denn eine sache dürfen wir echt
nicht aus dem blick lassen dass eine
pandemie die betrifft alle länder der
welt nahezu man kann davon auch lernt
von einigen ländern die das besonders
gut hingekriegt haben mit der pandemie
klar zu kommen also das ist ein element
des globalen denkens in dieser pandemie
und die andere ist halt das ja auch die
impfstoffe nicht überall gleich verteilt
sind also das ist in meinen augen ein
problem was wir auf jeden fall so
betrachten müssen also auch über den
tellerrand hinweg also es gibt echt orte
der welt wo es den leuten noch sehr viel
schlechter geht die zum beispiel kann
kein impfstoff front kommen genau also
das noch mal der appell im prinzip das
ganze immer global zu denken denn es ist
nun eine pandemie und da sind wir auch
erst sicher so bald sozusagen die
anderen staaten auf der welt auch über
genug impfstoff verfügen speed
korrigiert fragt uns über zdf über
youtube heute nach wie diese gibt es
denn in schweden nur eine masken
empfehlung und keine pflicht stimmt dass
das masken dann doch nicht so wirksam
sind also das muss man ja dann wohl fern
ein nachdem was wir auch gerade gesehen
haben auch gerade in bezug auf die fsp
zwei masken denn da geht er dann doch
ein relativ hoher schutz vor infektionen
einher mit ja diese masken studie war
sehr sehr wichtig weil sie einfach auch
mal so ein bisschen klarheit geschaffen
hat für die effektivität der ffp zwei
masten insbesondere dann wenn sie gut
sitzen also wenn man sie richtig an
bringt ich habe mir die studie
angeschaut ich habe auch ich kenne die
autoren herbert bodenschatz aus götting
zum beispiel mit dem ich gerade heute
gesprochen habe darüber dass es halt
wichtig dass wirklich zu verstehen dass
das so sagen die übertragungs
wahrscheinlichkeit extrem reduziert und
und deshalb ist es ein wichtiges element
aber das hatten wir ja in der gesamten
pandemie schon so dass auch ganz sehr
solide wissenschaftliche ergebnisse
nicht unbedingt in eine politik
übersetzt worden sind eine frage noch
von unserem user dj ginge denn auch die
durchseuchung der menschen dass man also
darauf setzt dabei aber alle 50
sozusagen vollständig impft und die
kollateralschäden derjenigen unter 50 in
kauf nimmt mit dem ziel herdenimmunität
was sagt aufgaben da habe ich eine ganz
klare und auch wissenschaftlich
fundierte meinung dazu und das ist der
grund ist ganz einfach ja mir das mit
einem virus zu tun über das wir sehr
viel wissen aber noch nicht alles longo
wird oder posco wird wie es jetzt heißt
ist im wesentlichen also es gibt
natürlich indikatoren dass bevor schon
gerade sehr viele menschen die
langzeitschäden die durch so eine
infektion entstehen übrigens auch bei
menschen die also automatisch verläufe
haben also die gar nicht so krank werden
die dann langzeitschäden haben das ist
im kern also wenn man das jetzt mal ein
bisschen schwarz und weiß mal
unverstanden und
eine durchsuchung einer gesamten
bevölkerung mit etwas was ich noch nicht
verstanden habe es halt fahrlässig ja
also hoch ist ganz mit anderen worten
wenn wir es jetzt noch mal
zusammenfassen professor brockmann wir
wollen sie jetzt auch nicht über die
gebühr hier bei uns erhalten wir gucken
gerade noch mal aufs podium sehen aber
dass da sich noch nichts tut wir warten
natürlich immer noch auf die politiker
nach dem bund länder treffen die uns
dann mitteilen was es eventuell neues
gibt an beschlüssen vielleicht nochmal
wie gesagt abschließend die frage an sie
professor brockmann welche maßnahmen
sind jetzt in der nächsten zeit aus
ihrer sicht die entscheidenden was ist
jetzt ganz besonders wichtig wie sollten
wir uns verhalten
postern im flug lücke schließen die
größte politische aufgabe den impfschutz
in der gesamten bevölkerung zu erhöhen
dass das erste die maßnahmen müssen
durchgesetzt werden und eingehalten
werden also das tragen von masken in
schulen oder aber auch das überprüfen
von 2g und 3g und 2g plus dass dessen
alles wirksame maßnahmen das hat lothar
wieler ja auch schon vor wochen gesagt
diese maßnahmen sind wirksam sie müssen
aber umgesetzt werden dann sind sie erst
wirksam sonst uns das ist ja noch auf
dem zettel aufgeschrieben das heißt es
muss umgesetzt werden und das muss
passieren dann wird es wirksam sein wir
müssen halt genau beobachten ob es
reicht momentan ist das schwer zu
entscheiden weil wir halt
keine direkte verbindung sehen zwischen
den maßnahmen immer das war ja auch in
der dritten welle und in der zweiten
welle so das heißt wir müssen diese
maßnahmen wirksam einsetzen dann genau
beobachten und zwar insbesondere die
inzidenz weil es die schnelle variable
ist die uns sehr schnell informiert wo
das infektionsgeschehen hingeht und da
sehen wir jetzt einen leichten trend
nach unten der muss ich halt noch weiter
und noch schneller nach unten fortsetzen
damit wir dann irgendwann sagen können
ob die maßnahmen haben gewirkt und wenn
das nicht schnell genug ist dann muss
man muss man überlegen was dann als
nächstes kommt professor dirk brockmann
war das für uns der korona modellierer
von der humboldt-universität in berlin
ganz herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
und dass wir uns so lange zur verfügung
gestanden haben einen schönen abend
dankeschön auch bitteschön so und dann
gucken wir doch noch mal nach berlin und
schauen ob sich denn inzwischen etwas
tut das seit das sieht gerade nicht
danach aus aber ich sehe hier in die kol
diekmann wieder neben mir auftauchen und
darüber freue ich mich sehr nicole schön
dass du noch bei uns bist und wieder bei
uns bist
was hast du in der letzten zeit in den
letzten minuten erfahren wird sich das
ganze noch ein bisschen hinziehen oder
was sind deine informationen im moment
bringt relativ wenig nach außen
anscheinend also gehen wir jetzt erstmal
ganz optimistisch davon aus dass es
heute nicht bis in die puppen geht denn
wir haben das ja zu beginn unserer
sendung ausschaut gesagt es ist jetzt
nicht der große kracher heute zu
erwarten das ist eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die schon
lange für heute anberaumt war es gab
dann vergangene woche eine die man quasi
vorgezogen hat weil die lage zu
dramatisch wurde die instanzen zu hoch
gingen sind sie ja immer noch die
intensivmediziner alle anschlugen
deswegen gab es letzte woche schon eine
können das ja vorhin im beitrag von
johanna sagt meister auch schon gehört
mit relativ weit reichenden konsequenzen
wie zum beispiel zwei geben einzelhandel
also kein weihnachts shopping mehr für
ungeimpfte oder leute die chinesen die
nicht genesen sind
oder auch masken pflicht wieder überall
in den schulen in allen
in allen schulklassen das heißt heute
gehen wir erst mal davon aus es wäre
nicht das erste mal dass sie überrascht
werden dass es nicht so viele strittige
punkte gibt beziehungsweise nicht so
viele möglichkeiten miteinander über
kreuz zu liegen aber
im moment sehen wir da setzt sich gerade
jemand auf einen stuhl stand aber nicht
olaf schulze es ist weder olaf scholz
soviel kann ich sagen auch nicht hendrik
wüst der nordrhein westfälische
ministerpräsident der ja der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz im moment
vorsitzt und michael müller regierender
bürgermeister in berlin sieht auch
anders aus also noch geht es nicht los
noch geht es nicht los dann konfrontiere
ich dich doch nicole noch mit ein paar
fragen unserer zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer nanu nana über youtube fragt
uns wie werden denn die sanktionen
aussehen wenn man sich trotz impfpflicht
nicht impfen lässt gibt es dazu schon
konkrete erkenntnisse ja das ist eine
sehr gute frage die kann ich aber nicht
beantworten
diese woche also morgen dann ist ja auch
schon wochenende morgen sondersitzung
und 13 uhr bundesrat einziger
tagesordnungspunkt änderung
infektionsschutzgesetz und darin ist
erstmal eine einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht vorgesehen das heißt wer in
einem krankenhaus arbeitet wer in einem
pflegeheim arbeitet in einem altersheim
muss sich impfen lassen die allgemeine
impfpflicht dass davon gehe ich mal aus
ist jetzt auch gerade während der noch
laufenden ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ein thema dieser jahr später kommen im
nächsten jahr es wäre ja auch unsinn
jetzt mit der allgemeinen pflicht
anzufangen und dann die einrichtungs
bezogen weil die hat sich dann ja quasi
erledigt wird überall im pflicht gilt
also so weit ist man einfach noch nicht
ja das bleibt also abzuwarten el matador
fragt uns über youtube wie wird es mit
der neuen regierung sein wird er
voraussichtlich wird es da einen
kurswechsel in der korona politik geben
also einen gravierenden kurswechsel wird
es ja wohl nicht geben aber ich will
nicht vorgreifen nicole die frage geht
an dich danke aber ich kann der neuen
natürlich nicht vorgreifen
gestern war vereidigung wahl des
kanzlers und vereidigung von olaf scholz
als kanzler und seines kabinetts aber
natürlich die frage stimmt schon
insofern als ja die ampel die seit
gestern regiert ja auch in den
vergangenen wochen schon in die korona
gesetzgebung aktiv eingegriffen hat es
wird diese woche noch mal nachgeschärft
habe ich ja eben schon gesagt also
kurswechsel naja also zu politischen pr
gehört natürlich auch von sich zu sagen
wir machen das jetzt besser das
behauptet die ampel also von sich wäre
blöd wenn sie es nicht machen würde
sie will jetzt die parlamente wieder
stärker einbeziehen und sagt von sich
gezieltere maßnahmen den ländern an die
hand geben das ist dieser jetzt schon
sehr oft
genannte instrumentenkasten
kritiker dieser neuen maßnahmen sagen es
war ein großer fehler der ampel die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite auslaufen zu lassen das eine
bedingt eben das andere aber
letztendlich
es ist eine pandemie so etwas gab es
noch nie dieses virus gab es noch nie
kurbelt ist neu auch wenn es jetzt
demnächst von zwei jahre quasi auf der
welt ist im wahrsten sinne des wortes
das ist so dynamisch also ich kann
leider nur sagen warten wir mal ab ob es
da einen kurswechsel gibt
vielen dank nicole für diese
einschätzungen bis hierhin du bleibst
noch ein bisschen bei uns aber momentan
tut sich halt eben noch nichts in berlin
und wir sprechen dann wieder spätestens
wenn sich daran etwas ändert und wenn
sich also was tut wir befassen uns noch
ein wenig mit der omicron variante also
mit dieser neuen mutante des corona
virus die derzeit natürlich für
schlagzeilen und auch für unruhe sorgt
über den aktuellen stand was unsere
erkenntnis angeht in bezug auf diese
variante berichtet julia schröter
knapp zwei wochen lang hat bei montech
geprüft wie gut sein impfstoff gegen
omikron wirkt erste ergebnisse zeigen
nun zwei impfdosen bieten keinen
ausreichenden schutz vor einer infektion
mit omikron vor einer deren erkrankung
schützen sie aber wohl weiterhin die
dritte impfung bietet dann wieder einen
deutlich größeren schutz forscher aus
südafrika und frankfurt am main hatten
zuvor ebenfalls impfstoff daten
veröffentlicht die in eine ähnliche
richtung weisen
zum einen muss man ganz klar sagen dass
die antikörper die durch die impfung
induziert werden immer noch gegen
omikron schützen können aber ich brauche
deutlich mehr das heißt er ich brauche
ungefähr 25 fach mehr es gibt andere
ergebnisse sagen sogar 40 fach mehr
antikörper um mikron zu neutralisieren
das bedeutet nur zweifach geimpft haben
mit omikron ein erhöhtes risiko sich
anzustecken das liegt daran dass omikron
vor allem amsbeck protein notiert ist
dort locken die antikörper normalerweise
an und machen das virus unschädlich
wegen der mutationen klappt das aber
nicht mehr so gut
daher läuft es wohl auf einen
angepassten im stoff hinaus
gemeinsam mit unserem partner pfizer
arbeiten wir weiter an einem an die
omikron variante angepassten impfstoff
das haben wir vor kurzem begonnen für
den fall dass es nötig wird unser ziel
wir wollen einen hohen und einen
anhaltenden schutz erreichen
im märz könnte so ein neuer impfstoff
zur verfügung stehen allerdings sollte
bis dahin niemand warten der einzige
schutz aktuell ist sagen experten sich
jetzt impfen und postern zu lassen
und wir sprechen jetzt mit frau
professor christian veith präsidentin
der deutschen gesellschaft für
immunologie einen schönen guten abend
und herzlich willkommen und nahm
gewähren wir haben gerade gesehen im
beitrag die ausbreitung von omikron
macht sorgen bevor wir auf die
besonderheiten dieser variante zu
sprechen kommen sind sie auch besorgt
besorgt bin ich nicht aber man sieht
dass wir jetzt ein neues virus haben das
noch ein bisschen mehr
infektiöser ist und sich möglicherweise
gegen geld da durchzusetzen versucht und
deswegen sollten wir tatsächlich ganz
hellwach sein um solche maßnahmen zu
ergreifen bietet braucht man sie eben
gerade genannt hat
a++ die booster impfung mehr
erstimpfungen wir auch nicht schlecht
damit wir einfach versuchen können diese
ausbreitung möglichst zu verhindern weil
wir haben schon genug probleme mit delta
wir brauchen nicht noch zusätzliche mit
omikron was sind dann die besonderheiten
dieser omikron variante wenn sie es
gerade noch mal auf den punkt bringen
man kann ja auch bei dieser corona
virusinfektionen kann man so einen
richtigen stammbaum erstellen wie die
sequenzen sich verändert haben von den
ursprungsvirus in china über die
variante die da in europa in die welt
ging und sich dann in den verschiedenen
varianten wie zum beispiel der delta und
jetzt der nikon variante quasi
weiterentwickelt hat und omikron hat
eine relativ eigen eigene linie gebildet
sozusagen und vereinigt ziemlich viele
mutationen allein in diesem stachel
proteinen dieses bike proteinen da sind
allein 30 stellen verändert da fehlt
manchmal auch kleine aminosäuren das
kann man sich vielleicht so vorstellen
dieses protein hat
1273 aminosäuren das sind wieso
perlenketten auf einer perlenschnur
perlen auf einer perlenkette und diese
perlenkette faltet sich dann in diese
dreidimensionale struktur die man immer
auf ihren schönen bildern sieht wenn sie
das ganze virus zeigen da sind ja immer
diese staffel proteine die da so rauscht
achsen aus diesen virus und die omikron
variante hat einfach 30 von diesen
1273 verändert das heißt es sind immer
noch sehr viele genauso im bauplan wie
das in fuchs variante war aber genau an
der stelle wo das virus in die zelle
reinkommt wenn es uns hier in den
nasen-rachen-raum fliegt da sind
veränderungen da so dass es noch
effektiver infizieren kann das ist die
eine seite und die andere ist dass die
antikörper die wir über die impfung
gebildet haben da gibt es verschiedene
klassen von antikörpern und die die da
oben ansetzen genau an dieser schlüssel
schloss position die binde nicht mehr
ganz so gut an omikron und deswegen
stützen die antikörper nicht mehr so gut
wie wir das gegen die ursprungs variante
oder gegen data eigentlich erwarten
würden das sind jetzt diese neuen daten
und deswegen hat karsten botts ganz
richtig gesagt wir brauchen quasi näher
antikörper damit wir doch noch einen
besseren schutz vor infektionen bekommen
vor einer schweren erkrankung schützt
uns die impfung also trotzdem ganz
wichtige messe du also die impfung ist
nicht wirkungslos sondern sie hat nur
diesen ersten teil nämlich verhinderung
der infektion etwas weniger gut auf dem
radar verstehe ja also wir haben ja
gerade im beitrag auch gehört also
erscheinen der der bankchef der sprache
selber davon dass laut eigenen
untersuchungen der impfschutz 25 fach
geringer ist korrigieren sie mich wenn
ich da falsch lege andere
untersuchungen gehen sogar von einem
noch drastischeren abfall des
impfschutzes aus heißt das dann am ende
dass es einen angepassten impfstoff dann
noch mal braucht
also vorneweg sollte man unbedingt sagen
dass diese aussagen beziehen sich nur
auf die frage wieviel virus kommt noch
in eine zelle ein die beziehen sich
nicht darauf wie gut das immunsystem
generell schützt vor einer schweren
erkrankung und zwar misst man das so um
dass einmal kurz zu sagen man nimmt
sozusagen die ziellinie und wirft dann
richtiges virus drauf und gibt dann die
antikörper dazu und die antikörper
verdünnten schrittweise um zu sehen wie
weit kann ich das serum und die
antikörper verdünnen und habe immer noch
eine einen schutz davor dass das virus
in die zelle hinein kommt also diese
aussagen beziehen sich wirklich nur auf
die frage wie gut kann die omikron
variante noch zellen infizieren und da
sieht man dass man eben nicht so gut
verdienen kann sondern man muss
tatsächlich hohe konzentrationen von
antikörpern hna im serum damit man
verhindern kann dass das virus in der
zellkultur auch zellen infiziert das ist
ja nur der allererste schritt unseres
immun schutzes dahinter kommen dann die
ganzen antikörper die auch noch an
dieses große speicher stick protein
binden aber halt die fresszellen
anlocken und noch eine schicht darunter
sind dann die t-zellen die sowieso erst
aktiv werden können wenn es in zellen
virus infiziert sind also haben wir
quasi drei ebenen der immunantwort frau
professor ganz wert ich will sie da
eigentlich gar nicht unterbrechen aber
ich würde ihnen noch eine hilfe mit an
die hand geben wollen die sie selber
erstellt haben da geht es um eine
fußball- analogie vielleicht könnten sie
darauf gerade auch noch einmal bezug
nehmen da haben sie das nicht gerne
erklärt mit diesen drei im prinzip
abwehrreihen die wir haben gegen das
virus ja sehr gerne das ist mein
lieblings fußball bild
vielleicht kann uns das nochmals schaden
an der stelle und sie sprechen einfach
mal drüber was damit gemeint ist und da
das meinte ich mit dieser abwehr linie
bevor man geimpft ist ist man quasi in
einem fußballspiel und das virus ist der
ball und unsere zellen im nasen rachen
raum sind das tor und wenn man noch
nicht geimpft ist dann ist es quasi eine
situation wie in elfmeter ohne torwart
weil ganz einfach dieses virus ohne
irgendwie aufgehalten zu werden direkt
in den nasen-rachen-raum einen fliegen
kann und dann gibt es überhaupt gar
keine chance des virus vorher abzuwehren
das ist die situation bevor man kämpft
ist wenn man dann die impfung hat
erstmal die zwei und eben wie das ganz
richtig gesagt wurde die drei sind quasi
jetzt in richtung vollständiger
impfschutz dann kann man sich das
vorstellen wie eine freistoßsituation da
steht dann die abwehr aus antikörpern
idealer weise wie eine mauer und was sie
erreichen wollen ist mit der impfung
dass bereits die mauer so gut steht dass
wenn das virus hier angeflogen kommt in
richtung nasen-rachen-raum dass dann die
antikörper es abwehren bevor es
überhaupt in die zellen rhein kann genau
das ist das erste bild das es ja der
elfmeter ohne torwart das war die erste
phase sozusagen gerne auch überhaupt
kein impfschutz besteht das
bild ist jetzt die situation nach der
impfung idealerweise nach der dritten da
steht die antikörper abwehr wie eine
mauer das virus kommt durch die mauer
nicht mehr durch die tatsache sich hier
hinten in meinem rachenraum t zellen
sitzen habe diese orangenen t zellen das
ist zwar gut aber ich brauche gar nicht
weil das virus kommt gar nicht so weit
das ist sozusagen die situation da
wollen wir uns alle hin boostern dass
die abwehr steht wie eine eins nach zwei
impfungen kann es aber sein dass die
abwehr so ein paar lücken hat es kommt
im fußball ja auch manchmal vor und dann
kann das virus durch diese abwehr lücke
durch schlüpfen und kann trotzdem noch
zellen infizieren das ist die situation
dass wir eben mit omikron lücken in der
abwehr haben das virus kann dadurch aber
wir haben nach der impfung immer noch
die t-zellen die dann dafür sorgen dass
virus infizierte zellen hier im tor also
tv torwart dass die t-zellen die zellen
begrenzen können die virus produzieren
deswegen wirkt die impfung immer noch
vor schwere erkrankungen weil das virus
gar nicht mehr weiter in die lunge
reinkommen kann weil sie wetter open
kontrolliert und wo wir eigentlich
wieder hinwollen ist dass wir aus diesem
quasi nicht so ganz perfekten zustand
nach dem puck mit der dritten impfung
wieder in diesem zustand geraten dass
wir eine ganz klare abwehrfront haben
und dass wir uns die leute gar nicht
mehr infizieren kann das ist mein
lieblings fußball beispiel weil ich
glaube da kann man sich ganz gut
vorstellen wie diese abwehr
fronten arbeiten ja in der tat das ist
sehr anschaulich das hat uns schon mal
sehr gefallen und auch heute finde ich
es wieder sehr hilfreich bei der
vorstellung wie unsere abwehrkräfte da
funktionieren abus fragt uns über
youtube könnte der milde verlauf von
omikron darauf hinweisen dass das virus
in dem es wird
das ist ehrlicher weise noch ein
bisschen zu früh um wirklich klar sagen
zu können dass omikron generell mädel
verläufe macht denn was man aus
südafrika sieht ist das omikron vor
allem menschen infiziert die vorher
schon mal infiziert waren also eine
gewisse in den immunstatus haben daher
weiß man auch dass es eben möglich ist
sich nochmal anzustecken und zwar mit
der omicron variante daher sind die
aussagen wie gefährlich oder wie sehr
krank machend es wirklich ist nicht so
wirklich eindeutig für mich persönlich
ist es zu früh um zu sagen ist es
wirklich weniger krank machen das wäre
zwar die bessere variante gar keine
frage aber ich glaube nicht dass wir das
jetzt schon sagen können also ich würde
nicht so weit gehen dass es schon ein
hinweis darauf ist dass es sich in
anführungszeichen anpasst im sinne von
zwar ansteckender macht aber weniger
krank das würde ich gerne noch mit
zahlen bestätigt sehen eigentlich
ehrlich ich möchte ich gerne nicht dass
sich viele menschen mit omikron
infizieren aber gerade die zahlen die
wir haben sind noch ein bisschen zu dünn
um das wirklich sagen zu können welche
bedeutung hat denn das boostern karl
lauterbach der neue gesundheitsminister
der sagt nur nach drei impfungen ist man
vollständig geimpft also so in etwa hat
er das ausgedrückt also heißt das dann
das 2g auch nur noch mit dritter
impfungen in zukunft zu haben ist wie
sehen sie das
also wir haben ja in diesem fußball
beispiel schon gesehen dass wir für
omicron quasi die best stehen der abwehr
brauchen die wir irgendwie kriegen
können und das ist immer so wenn man die
frage stellt wie wie gut muss unser
impfschutz seien hat es immer was auch
damit zu tun wie viel virus ist in der
gesellschaft und im moment haben wir
leider sehr viel virus wir haben allein
von gestern 70.000 neuinfektionen da
stockt mir immer der atem weil ich mir
dann denke 70.000 es eine riesenzahl die
uns sagt wie viel virus in der
gesellschaft ist deswegen brauchen wir
möglichst viele antikörper das höchste
niveau das wir irgendwie erreichen
können und dazu brauchen wir die dritte
impfung weil eindeutig gezeigt werden
konnte wenn man zweimal geimpft war hat
man zwar antikörper die gehen aber
wieder ein bisschen runter weil das
immunsystem arbeitet ökonomisch man
brauchte ja nicht immer und wenn man sie
dann noch mal mit der dritten impfung
wirklich noch mal auf das höchste niveau
bringt hat man automatisch auch den
besten schutz und dadurch dass wir jetzt
in die ross haben das möglicherweise
noch mehr antikörper braucht um sich
aufhalten zu lassen es ist so dass man
sagen kann jetzt auch hier
wahrscheinlich tatsächlich diese drei
impfungen ob man das dann so umsetzt
dass wirklich alle menschen nur diesen
pass quasi bekommen nach drei impfungen
da wäre ich ein bisschen vorsichtig weil
es schon menschen gibt die mit der
dritten impfung nicht unbedingt immer so
gut bedient sind wie die menschen wie
wir die wie keine großen nebenwirkungen
hatten da muss man auch so ein bisschen
aufpassen ob man das wirklich
pragmatisch durchziehen kann ich glaube
die linie dass alle menschen die das gut
vertragen haben eine dritte impfung
unbedingt brauchen und zwar jetzt so
schnell wie möglich ungefähr ein halbes
jahr nach der zweiten das ist glaube ich
das wichtigste
ob man das wirklich so umgesetzt dass
man auch unsere impfpässe entsprechend
anpasst so ein bisschen vorsichtig weil
das hat noch ganz andere implikationen
der muss möchte ein bisschen die
pragmatische seite im blick behalten ja
wir kommen gleich noch mal auf das thema
kinder und impfungen beziehungsweise
kinder und infektionen zu sprechen
vorher noch die frage von isegrim
rokitte über youtube gilt denn eine impf
serie auch als abgeschlossen bei zwei
impfungen und einer inflation wie ist
das ja es ist eine sehr gute frage es
ist ja so wir impfen ja nur mit dem
stachel protein mit dem bike wenn man
sich dann danach infiziert hat dann hat
man ja das ganze virus aufgenommen in
sich und idealerweise war das
hoffentlich dann ein leichter verlauf
weil die impfung ja eben gerade das kann
nämlich nach infektion sehr gut abwehren
dass das virus sich im körper weiter
ausbreitet aber das virus bringt
natürlich noch ungefähr 30 andere
proteine mit also hat man nach einer
infektion dann nochmal 30 weitere
proteine gegen die der körper reagiert
und das ist natürlich nicht nur eine
verstärkung der ursprünglichen antwort
gegen spike dagegen die antikörper
nochmal deutlich hoch das kann man auch
sehr gut messen haben wir ja auch schon
gesehen sondern man kriegt auch noch
neue antigene also nochmal neue
antikörper und hat damit einen sehr
guten impfschutz das ist tatsächlich so
und deswegen würde man schon sagen
lautet die zweimal geimpft sind und sich
dann dummerweise doch das virus
eingefangen haben das kann einem
heutzutage echt passieren dann hat man
natürlich in den sehr guten impfschutz
mir ist aber total wichtig zu sagen dass
es keine strategie sein soll also bitte
nicht so nach dem motto na ja kann mir
nichts passieren dann hole ich mir
vielleicht doch noch eine infektion
bitte nicht weil es ist schon so dass
das virus unberechenbar ist und man
möchte eigentlich nicht dass man doch
noch irgendein risiko hat dass es gar
nicht braucht also die strategie sich
irgendwie bewusst dann doch mit dem
virus in verbindung zu setzen ist gar
keine gute lieber dreimal im und das
würde ich gern noch mal ganz deutlich
sagen ist rübergekommen bevor wir dann
über die jungen sprechen vielleicht noch
mal über die älteren denn claus kaminsky
fragt uns können die älteren menschen
über 80 nach einer booster impfung
anfang september beziehungsweise oktober
mit einer erneuten impfung februar märz
rechnet also muss man selbst nach dem
booster noch mal nachlegen wenn man ein
gewisses alter erreicht hat
also genau da muss man einfach sagen
dass das immunsystem mit uns mithalten
wir erleben viel im laufe unseres lebens
und je älter wir sind desto mehr haben
wir erlebt und auch unser immunsystem
lebt mit uns mit deswegen haben die
älteren menschen gerade über 80 einfach
ein repertoire das schon ein bisschen
was an erfahrung gesammelt hat und nicht
mehr ganz so frisch ist wie das bei den
jüngeren leuten deswegen ist der imf
antwort nicht ganz so gut das haben wir
jetzt gemerkt da haben wir ja auch
angefangen mit der dritten impfung und
es kann schon sein dass bei den älteren
leuten dann auch die dritte impfung
nicht so ganz so lang anhält weil
natürlich auch diese frage wieviel
antikörper wird produziert so ein
bisschen was mit dem alter zu tun hat
ich kann mir ganz gut vorstellen slim
türe die hat ja gesagt möglicherweise
haben wir so das ende des ersten
quartals einen angepassten impfstoff was
man sich für die älteren leute gut
vorstellen könnte nur also skizzierung
für die zukunft ganz vorsichtig
formuliert dass man die grippeimpfung
und die korona impfung kombiniert das
ist nämlich von der stiko auch empfohlen
so dass man dann immer für die menschen
für die sowieso auch eine grippeimpfung
empfohlen wurde die dann gleich
kombiniert mit einer corona impfung und
möglicherweise kann man da die varianten
sogar mit dazu packen so dass man dann
für diese gruppe die jedoch ein höheres
risiko hat einfach noch mal eine sehr
gute impfstrategie hat die sich gar
nicht so sehr von dem unterscheidet was
wir jetzt haben nämlich die empfehlung
sich gegen grippe impfen zu lassen und
dann kann man das vielleicht kombinieren
das wäre so eine möglichkeit die ich mir
vorstellen könnte
uns impfung wird da vorgeschlagen wir
hatten es gerade gesagt wir gucken immer
noch mal nach berlin aber da tut sich in
der tat im moment auch noch nichts mehr
warten geduldig weiter wir hatten die
frage für uns schon mal an gerissen wie
gefährlich ist umgekommen für kinder und
dazu hat sich auch karl lauterbach
gestern im zdf heute journal geäußert
und er hat er durchaus auch ernste und
zu nachdenklich stimmende worte gefunden
ich habe mich zum beispiel sehr
also in den medien dafür eingesetzt dass
in den schulen wieder die masken pflicht
eingeführt wird wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass also gerade die omikron
variante für kinder besonders bedrohlich
ist dass das ist leider so dass die
omikron variante sich nicht nur
schneller verbreitet sondern leider auch
kinder stärker befällt und somit auch zu
mehr krankenhauseinweisungen führen wird
das heißt wir müssen hier vor bauen ich
hoffe dass wir sehr bald zu einer stiko
bewertung der impfstoffe auch kommenden
dar dass gruppe der fünf bis
zwölfjährigen und bei den älteren ist es
so also ich persönlich
also jetzt als wissenschaftler
gesprochen glaube dass die impfung die
bessere wahl ist im vergleich zur
erkrankung
ja eben vom besser war als erkrankung
willkommen gleich auf die impfung noch
mal zu sprechen auch für die jüngeren
aber nochmal ganz allgemein gefragt wie
gefährdet sind denn ihrer einschätzung
nach ist die kinder wir haben gerade die
doch ja sehr nachdenklich stimmenden
worte gehört von herr lauterbach wir
können vielleicht auch gerade noch mal
eine zahl in den raum stellen 100.000
infektionen mehr als hunderttausend sind
es inzwischen an den schulen das ist
eine steigerung von zehn prozent noch
einmal gegenüber der vorwoche das hat
jetzt nicht alles direkt mit uns zu tun
aber generell macht ist sie das haben
sie mir im vorgespräch auch schon gesagt
auch nachdenklich ja
wir sehen eigentlich seit dem sommer
seit wir diese permanent an steigenden
infektionszahlen haben dass die höchsten
infektionszahlen als incident berechnet
wirklich in der altersgruppe von 9 bis
14 sind und dann ausstrahlend jüngeren
und die etwas älteren also haben wir
wirklich ein infektionsgeschehen dass
sie sehr viel in dieser gruppe der auch
unter zehnjährigen bis 12 zwischen 25
ungefähr abspielt und da sind natürlich
sehr viele schulkinder dabei und wir
sehen schon mit delta dass es
ansteckender ist auch bei dieser
kindergruppe natürlich wissen wir auch
dass es nur wenig symptome hat nur für
mich persönlich als immunologin muss ich
sagen ich habe über diese leichten fälle
die sich infiziert haben an den
erwachsenen so die junge
und erwachsene um die 20 jahre da sehen
wir ziemlich immun veränderungen selbst
nachdem die infektion lange ausgeheilt
ist einhalten es ist ihm unterstehen
immer noch so ein bisschen anders
zusammengesetzt als es ohne virus wäre
da wir nicht wissen wie das bei den
kindern aussieht habe ich ein großes
misstrauen gegen dieses virus auch bei
kindern und würde ganz gerne verhindern
dass kinder sich anstecken weil wir
nicht übersehen sollten dass wir keine
gute idee haben was es wirklich
langfristig bedeutet wenn ein kind sich
angesteckt hat auch wenn die symptome
nicht so stark sind und daher ist es so
dass wir ja nicht ein höheres risiko
haben dass die kinder schwer erkranken
aber trotzdem gibt es immerhin ungefähr
0,4 prozent wenn ich das richtig im kopf
hat der kinder brauchen eben doch einen
krankenhausaufenthalt und bei omikron
und des sozialen diese brücke darüber zu
schlagen gibt es aus südafrika
hinweise die noch sehr mit vorsicht zu
genießen sind weil kleine zahlen die
haben wir gerade sommer da muss man ein
bisschen aufpassen aber das eben doch
tendenziell kinder sich anstecken und
dann eben doch auch im krankenhaus
aufenthalt brauchen da wäre ich
sozusagen auch da würde ich diesen virus
keine sekunde trauen und mir lieber
denken okay sollte das so sein sollten
wir vorbereitet sein wie bereitet man
sich vor in dem sich kinder am besten
gar nicht anstecken die maßnahmen hat
der neue bundesgesundheitsminister ja
gerade genannt also wir sollten
versuchen schule möglich zu machen aber
gleichzeitig so dass die kinder sich
möglichst nicht anstecken und die frage
des impfens ist ja eh so dass ab 12 die
stiko empfehlung ja vorhanden ist dass
alle kinder ab zwölf jahren geimpft
werden können und es wird jetzt in
dieser woche noch eine neue
stellungnahme geben heute gibt schon die
kurzversion auf der webseite der stiko
dass man für die kinder von 5 ab fünf
jahren eine eingeschränkte empfehlung
hat das kennen wir aus der anderen
altersgruppe 12 bis 17 auch dass man
sagt die kinder die ein höheres risiko
haben schwer zu erkranken zum beispiel
herzfehler haben oder trisomie 21 oder
andere grunderkrankungen für die ist
auch jetzt schon die impfung empfohlen
für die gesunden kinder sozusagen noch
nicht explizit dennoch ist sie möglich
das ist also genau das gleiche verfahren
jetzt was wir für die zwölf- bis
17-jährigen davor hatten wunderbar da
sie das schon so kompakt erklärt haben
wir wollen dass gerade noch mal ein
bisschen illustrieren wie haben dazu
einen beitrag vorbereitet von dominic
moore la russa
vitus und till sind zwillinge vitus ist
gesund till hat eine vorerkrankung ein
nervenleiden heute sollen sie beide
geimpft werden kinderärzte in folge
bringt man an der uni klinik bochum ist
froh dass sie nun beide jungs impfen
kann mit rückendeckung der stiko
erleichtert unsere arbeit sehr wenn wir
eine offizielle stiko empfehlung haben
weil wir dann die sicherheit haben dass
das auch gut geprüft und empfohlen ist
und auch rechtlich eben ganz ganz gut
abgesichert und das ist etwas was uns
das impfen erleichtert das natürlich
aber auch den eltern die entscheidung
noch mal erleichtert sich dafür zu
entscheiden seit zwei stunden ist es
offiziell die stiko empfiehlt eine cupid
impfung für kinder mit vorerkrankungen
oder für kinder in deren umfeld
besonders gefährdete personen leben
kinder ohne vorerkrankung können auch
geimpft werden nach entsprechender
ärztliche aufklärung so die stiko im
moment will sie aber noch nicht allen
kindern uneingeschränkt eine impfung
empfehlen da es noch nicht genug daten
gebe es
ist damit zu rechnen
dazu
daten haben
vitus und hilfs mutter ist erleichtert
ihre kinder sind nun wie impft eines mit
expliziter stiko empfehlung das andere
eben ohne
[Musik]
ja das eine mit das andere ohne
vielleicht an der stelle gerade mal
eingeschoben frau professor falk lob an
sie von lascana bei facebook aber nur
stellvertretend natürlich für viele
andere sie erklärt die
wissenschaftlichen grundlagen wunderbar
so dass alles verstehen können wenn alle
es verstehen wollen hervorragend gebe
ich gerne hier mit an sie weiter und
dann noch mal per mail die frage von
endpunkt shell ginnheimer ein virus
mutiert insofern wird es immer wieder
neue varianten geben sollen wir uns denn
dann alle vier monate impfen lassen wird
es darauf hinauslaufen
wie sollen wir nicht
also das ist mir wirklich ganz wichtig
noch mal zu sagen deswegen habe ich das
von mit der perlenkette nochmal so
ausführlich erklärt dieses virus muss
jahr grund dinge nach wie vor
beibehalten ist muss in die zellen
reinkommen und es muss in den zellen
dann dafür sorgen dass die
umprogrammierten werden nämlich von bis
gestern haben wir schleim produziert ab
morgen produzieren wie viren und diese
grundlagen kann es nicht so verändern
dass es sich total verändert für uns
wäre quasi das beste windows virus so
verändert dass es gar nicht mehr in die
zellen reinkommt aber das den gefallen
wird es uns nicht tun weil diese wären
die sehen wir dann gar nicht also muss
es bestimmte grundformen auch in diesen
zwei proteinen beibehalten weil sonst
verliert ist seine eigenschaften und
dann zerstört es sich quasi selber
deswegen bin ich relativ zuversichtlich
dass wir zwei varianten sehen werden
also omikron hat jetzt schon 30 von
1273 perlen ausgetauscht vielleicht
sehen wir eine variante die 50
ausgetauscht hat aber es bleiben dann
immer noch 1200 genauso wie in der
ursprungs variante und wir machen auch
gegen diese regionen antikörper und die
sind total wichtig weil das kann man
auch messen dass diese antikörper
tatsächlich immer auch gebildet werden
und die können immer noch alle varianten
erkennen nur das sind halt nicht die
neutralisieren weil die sitzen sozusagen
an der falschen seite sie können nicht
neutralisieren aber die können zum
beispiel fest sein aktivieren und
deswegen bin ich der immunologisch
fundierten ansicht dass die impfstoffe
die wir jetzt haben so eine
grundimmunisierung macht
wo wir antikörper und t zellen bilden
die quasi eine breite möglichkeit von
varianten abdecken und nur die die
wirklich hoch spezialisiert sind und
diese infektionen abwehren können das
sind die dann bei omikron einknicken
weil sie diese omikron variante nicht
mehr so gut erkennen können und daher
kann es schon sollen das weitere
varianten kommen vor allem in ländern wo
sehr viel virus zirkuliert deswegen
sollten wir dafür sorgen dass in diesen
ländern auch geimpft wird weil das ist
wirklich so wenn wir nur den luxus haben
dass wir hier drei mal geimpft sind und
die anderen länder gar nicht haben wir
genau das was wir haben nämlich
varianten die da angeschleppt werden
also weltweit dafür sorgen dass
impfstoff vorhanden ist und dann werden
wir glaube ich möglicherweise wenn
wirklich sehr virulente varianten
hochkommen ab und zu mal nach vielleicht
eben mit der grippeimpfung zusammen aber
ich würde jetzt im moment ganz
vorsichtig in die glaskugel gucken sagen
wie ich rechne nicht damit dass wir alle
vier monate komplett neuem fließen
sondern wenn dann setzen wir auf dieser
sehr robusten grundimmunisierung auf das
also ein kurzer einschub was das impfen
generell angeht wir waren ja eigentlich
gerade bei den kindern gewesen da fragt
uns auch nochmal michaela lebhaft mein
sohn ist genesen sie schreibt jetzt
nicht wie alt er ist nach einer corona
infektion ende april im sommer geimpft
und hat nun seine zweite impfung
erhalten wir gehen davon aus dass das
dann die booster impfung ist ist das
korrekt zu
das ist sehr sehr logisch kombiniert und
korrekt so diese erste infektion hat
schon eine art grundimmunisierung
geschaffen dann hat man zwei mal geimpft
und für das bike protein kann man dann
eben sagen dass diese neue impfung
darauf zweimal sogar wirklich die beste
antikörper kapazität aktiviert hat
jemand sich so denken kann und deswegen
würde ich das genauso sehen das ist im
prinzip wie eine dritte impfung des bike
das kann man auch sehr gut messen
übrigens leute die infiziert waren und
dann geimpft sind da bleiben die anderen
antikörper natürlich auf dem niveau wo
sie malen in der infektion waren und
gehen auch leicht runter und nur das
bike reagiert und geht noch mal hoch die
antikörper gehen da richtig schön
nochmal an das maximum heran da kann man
auch sehr gut sehen wie genau das
immunsystem unterscheiden kann zwischen
ich werde nochmal nach kämpft und macht
bike antikörper und den rest
interessiert es gar nicht es ist ja ein
doch muss man sagen ziemlich kontrovers
diskutiertes thema gerade auch eben die
impfpflicht insbesondere für die
jüngeren kinder und da vielleicht auch
gerade nochmal die persönliche frage an
sie wenn sie kinder hätten in dem alter
auch zwischen 5 und 11 würden sie impfen
lassen
also ich hab leider keine kinder wissen
so eine patchworkfamilie mit großen
kindern inzwischen aber wenn ich kinder
hätte ab fünf jahren dann würde ich das
wirklich aus voller überzeugung tun und
zwar deshalb weil die aus den
zulassungsstudien ja sehen wie das
risikoprofil sich darstellt und es
unterscheidet sich soweit wir das jetzt
gesehen haben nicht von dem der kinder
ab zwölf jahren bis 17 jahren da haben
wir ja weltweit mehrere millionen kinder
inzwischen auch in deutschland die
geimpft wurden und es ist gerade heute
der sicherheits der wochenbericht des rk
ii jetzt gerade 14 minuten raus gekommen
wo man wieder sehr gut sehen kann wie
gut die impfung schützt vor infektionen
und schwere erkrankung auch in der
gruppe der 12 bis 17 jährigen und für
die kleineren kinder ist es tatsächlich
so dass natürlich weiter daten gesammelt
werden müssen das ist vollkommen richtig
dass die stiko sagt dafür brauchen wir
eine bessere datenbasis deswegen die
eingeschränkte empfehlung die heute
veröffentlicht wurde aber wir kriegen
diese daten ja und wir werden sehen wie
das risiko und sicherheitsprofil sich
darstellt und auf der basis dieser
kontinuierlich neu generierten daten
wird man dann sehen ob es dann auch noch
eine erweiterte empfehlung geben wird
also daher würde ich das tatsächlich aus
als immunologin wirklich auch für meine
kinder so machen um sie zu schützen dass
sie sich infizieren klare worte dann
genau wollen wir bevor wir dann gleich
nochmal zur nikon variante kommen weil
das auch sehr viele unserer userinnen
und user interessiert noch mal die
fragerei nehmen von schaeffler tag über
youtube geht die drei impfungen
empfehlung auch für personen die als
erste impfung johnson & johnson hatten
davon hört und liest man nie etwas nur
zum hintergrund das ist ja der impfstoff
wo eigentlich eine impfung ausreichend
sein sollte
ja das ist ein sehr guter hinweis weil
das jetzt auch viele leute gibt die
johnson & johnson bekommen haben die
zulassung von johnson johnson stammt aus
einer zeit als wir diese variante hatten
und da war für die zulassungsstudie
ausreichend dass die leute nur eine
impfung gebraucht haben inzwischen haben
wir delta und jetzt haben wir data plus
vielleicht omikron und da ist völlig
klar dass dieser eine impfung nicht
reicht deswegen diese auffrischimpfung
die gilt für alle im schemata die es
vorher gab inklusive johnson & johnson
mit dieser einen impfung dann war
sowieso schon klar dass es eine zweite
brauchen muss weil wirklich auch so
diese gedächtnisfunktion eine zweite in
wollen weil es auch klar ist dass wir
einfach für data die höchstmöglichen
antikörper spiegel brauchen die wir
haben können das geht auch wenn man
vorher johnson johnson bekommen hat ich
hoffe jetzt beantwortet die frage bei
johnson johnson mit die frage einmal und
dann nochmal oder nur einmal also
faustregel wäre dreimal egal welche
kommen wie das feuer war ist auf jeden
fall das was jetzt angesagt ist ja das
ist doch noch mal ein klarer merksatz
wir hatten gerade angesprochen omikron
ist momentan so das thema weil das eben
als neue variante dazu gekommen ist und
es doch viele beunruhigt auch nach den
aussagen noch mal des neuen
bundesgesundheitsministers wir haben
vorhin schon angesprochen und auch
auszüge aus seinem interview gestern im
heute-journal schon gezeigt wir wollen
gerade nochmal einen beitrag einspielen
von christoph distel der uns ein round
up gibt über die situation mit micon in
deutschland im moment
wie viel omikron fälle gibt es aktuell
in deutschland ein paar hundert schätzen
virologen 28 davon sind offiziell
bestätigt die zahl dürfte aber rasant
steigen wie ansteckend ist omikron sehr
wahrscheinlich sehr über 30 mutationen
am bei der infektion so wichtigen
stachel machen es dem virus offenbar
besonders leicht sich zu verbreiten
wie gefährlich ist eine infektion mit
omikron auf diese kernfrage antworten
forscher unterschiedlich in den usa eher
zuversichtlich
bei drei viertel unserer omikron fälle
handelt es sich um geimpfte aber immer
verläuft die krankheit mild
deutsche forscher sind etwas
vorsichtiger ein trend zeichnet sich
aber ab da sieht es nicht so aus als ob
das jetzt deutlicher krank macht oder so
inwieweit schützt eine booster impfung
jetzt auch vor omikron virologen sagen
boostern legt noch einmal die gesamte
immunabwehr des körpers dürfte also
zumindest schwere verläufe verhindern
auch bei neuen varianten
sollte man bei der auffrischung den
impfstoff wechseln das sogenannte kreuz
boostern kann man machen aber besser
nicht empfiehlt die whu obwohl einiges
dafür spricht und zwar wenn ich dann
einen m rna im stoff für die dritten da
funktioniert sowohl bei montech sehr gut
als auch vor allem moderner sehr gut das
haben studien gezeigt so oder so die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde ema red
ab heute dazu schnell nach zu boostern
also nicht erst nach sechs sondern schon
nach drei monaten
das ist das also in der tat eine
sozusagen doch zunehmende rasant also
nicht nach sechs sondern nach drei
monaten dann wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
wieder ordentlich in drangeben auf die
impfzentren beziehungsweise die
arztpraxen wie bewerten sie das also ist
das offenbar doch so dass man sagen muss
okay also jetzt doch lieber schneller
boostern als später
also da will ich ehrlicherweise diese
drei monate so ein bisschen
ist sagen die geschwindigkeit da
rausnehmen immunologisch ist diese sechs
monate
ursprünglich diskutiert waren die sind
ja kein immunologischer zeitpunkt
sondern die waren ein epidemiologisch
reg strich logistischer zeitpunkt damit
wir wieder so ein bisschen die idee
haben wenn der run auf die zentren
losgeht haben wir wieder das was wir
genau nicht wollen die leute stehen
schlange auf der straße ist es eiskalt
draußen und dann ist der impfstoff aus
das macht ja nicht wirklich sind die
idee war eigentlich schon diese im
priorisierung die wir hatten die war ja
basierte ja auf den risikogruppen das
war ja schon im prinzip richtig und das
vielleicht auch noch mal zu übersetzen
in eine zeitabfolge um zu sagen ungefähr
ein halbes jahr und bitte erst vor allem
die risikogruppen da sind wir ja auch
schon relativ gut dabei das läuft
zumindest an und dann sollen die anderen
ab 18 jahren eben auch diese dritte
auffrischimpfung bekommen drei monate
ist für mich immer logisch echt ein
bisschen früh weil das immunsystem baut
sich kontinuierlich auf nach der zweiten
krieg und sozusagen ja eines jeden tag
ein stückchen mehr bessere antikörper
das ist wirklich so dass seine aktion im
körper stattfindet dass mehr antikörper
produziert werden es kommen auch noch
ein paar neue klone nach die zellen
entwickeln sich in gedächtniszellen und
nisten sich dann im knochenmark ein
deswegen sieht man die nicht so gut aber
sie sind da also hat man da echt so eine
zeitschiene von drei monaten wurde es
sehr gut abläuft und wenn ich dann schon
wieder rein dann ist es für das
immunsystem gar nicht so toll weil es
bringt nicht so viel ich bin ja sowieso
gerade in der obersten plateau phase
dann
verbandstoffe noch mal und erreichte gar
nicht so viel da machen diese vier
monate bis sechs eigentlich deutlich
mehr sinn also bitte jetzt nicht in
brand ab drei monaten sozusagen los
treten es braucht tatsächlich
immunologisch nicht weil die drei monate
sind noch in dieser phase der antikörper
da muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt
zwingend daraufhin das bringt ja nichts
also sind diese vier ist mir auch schon
fast ein bisschen zu früh
56 und wenn es sieben monate sind wirkt
es ja trotzdem das ist ja nicht so dass
wir so eine art verfallsdatum für die
impfstoffe im gegenteil natürlich werden
die antikörper ein bisschen weniger aber
das gedächtnis ist da und so springt
auch noch nach sieben monaten oder sogar
ein jahr
an da muss man sich jetzt wirklich keine
gedanken machen daher jetzt noch weiter
nach vorne verlegen bringt irgendwie nix
außer dass es noch mehr stress gibt es
muss ja nicht sein dann haben wir glaube
ich mit diesen vier ab 4 idealerweise
fünf bis sechs wenn man glaube ich sehr
gut dabei ja also quasi der aufruf zur
deeskalation und sogar gegen panik die
einen jetzt befallen könnte weil man
irgendwie denkt man müsste jetzt ganz
schnell zur musterung dem ist nicht so
wie sie gerade ja sehr nachvollziehbar
geschildert haben im beitrag wurden auch
die kreuz impfungen noch einmal erwähnt
dass auch ein thema was viele userinnen
und user von uns beschäftigt kann man da
eine allgemeine aussage treffen muss man
sagen hauptsache überhaupt drei mal
geimpft oder muss man da auf die
zusammensetzung der verschiedenen
impfstoffe mit denen man dann geimpft
worden ist doch sehr achten
also die empfehlung gibt es ja sowieso
für zwei impfstoffe nämlich einmal für
biotech den impfstoff also community und
für moderner strucks bei moderner ist es
so dass da die halbe dosis eingesetzt
werden soll also nur die 50 mikrogramm
statt der 100 und bei barren tag bleibt
die dosis das sind zweimal oder dreimal
30 mikrogramm diese beiden -männer
impfstoffe sind die wirklich identisch
da ist der bauplan identisch die
verpackung ist identisch das was im
körper gebildet wird alsbald protein
nach diesem bauplan ist identisch daher
ist es wirklich gar kein problem
moderner oder oder biotec zu bekommen
die sind da ich fertig das ist ganz
wichtig an der stelle zu sagen weil
diese beiden impfstoffe gerade als
dritte impfung wirklich da noch mal eine
sehr sehr gute aktivität zeigen und bei
moderner ist es sogar so dass es ein
bisschen mehr konzentration drin ist das
holt vielleicht so ticken mir aber
nichts was man jetzt irgendwie als
echten wird effekt argumentieren würde
sondern diese beiden ehemänner
impfstoffe sind in der dritten impfung
extrem gut machen die antikörper noch
mal mehr und schützen daher sehr gut und
sind absolut vergleichbar also was sie
kriegen können nehmen sie bitte mal die
sind beide wirklich sozusagen
gleichwertig gerade in der dritten
impfung flint sie schreibt uns über
youtube ich weiß nicht ob ein skeptiker
ist aber er fragt inwiefern wird
beachtet oder beobachtet ob das impfen
selbst neue mutationen fördert bzw zu
einer schnelleren mutation des virus
beiträgt hat dass ein zusammenhang ja
das wird immer diskutiert übungsleiter
vergessen moderner hat eine alters
einschränkungen auch von der stiko
bekomme ich fast vergessen ein moderner
soll ab 30 jahren gegeben werden das
darf ich nicht vergessen da der
korrektheit halber ja natürlich immer
muss immer so ein bisschen im hinterkopf
haben dass wenn man jetzt impft dann hat
man natürlich ganz viele menschen wie
hier wir haben jetzt dem und über 57
millionen menschen in deutschland die
geimpften mindestens einmal idealerweise
dreimal und die haben natürlich
antikörper wenn ich jetzt ein virus wäre
dann würde ich natürlich versuchen wir
so zu verändern dass sich diese
antikörper antwort unterlaufe das muss
man beobachten bis jetzt muss man
fairerweise sagen die länder die sehr
hohe impfquoten haben portugal zum
beispiel auch spanien ist sehr hoch das
werden ja die länder wo sich am ehesten
so genannte flucht mutanten ausbilden
würden das ist aber nicht der fall das
ist auch immunologisch ganz gut zu
erklären weil das virus müsste sich ja
in einer person quasi so verändern dass
es genau diesen antikörpern entkommt in
einer person kann sich aber gar nicht so
toll verändern weil unser immunsystem
ist platt macht also kommt es virus gar
nicht soweit
varianten immer bis jetzt hergekommen
sind in england in indien und jetzt
haben wir südafrika gab es vorher schon
welche auch brasilien waren immer länder
in denen die inzidenz sehr hoch war also
viele menschen infiziert waren und in
süd auf da kommen noch einen aspekt dazu
deswegen wundert es einen nicht wirklich
dass es daher kommt es gibt in südafrika
leider relativ viele menschen im
gegensatz zu hier die hiv positiv sind
und dieses hiv-virus dämpft ja auch das
immunsystem war es ausgerechnet
immunzellen infiziert ist immer ganz
ungeschickt und diese menschen wenn die
sich damit corona infizieren die kämpfen
zum teil wochenlang mit sonnen virus
weise ist einfach nicht gut los werden
können weil das immunsystem ja selber
durch hiv schon geschwächt ist und
dieser pool sozusagen von menschen die
doppelt infiziert sind hiv und da noch
genauer auf da ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit relativ hoch dass das
virus wochen lang zeit hat sogar in
einer person sich zu verändern daher ist
so diese frage wann verändern sich die
viren er damit verknüpft wann können sie
lang in einem menschlichen körper
zirkulieren und sich schrittweise
verändern das passiert ja nicht so über
nacht sondern das ist ja ein prozess und
daher ist es ganz wichtig die welt als
gewählt gemeinschaft zu verstehen die
geimpft werden muss denn sonst werden
wir immer solche länder haben in denen
gerade viel virus unterwegs ist und da
ist besteht die gefahr dass es sich dort
verändert aber nicht so sehr in den
ländern die impfen weil da kommt einfach
gar nicht so weit sich zu verändern so
weit wie es jetzt bewerten können per
mail erreicht uns die frage von isolde
kolb wie gefährlich kann das corona
virus in sachen sterblichkeit durch
mutationen werden kann man eine mutation
die ausmaße wie ebola hat ausschließen
das ist eine sehr gute frage weil diese
frage wie gefährlich und krank machen
sind viren immer was damit zu tun hat
welche zellen infizieren sie wie kommen
sie in den körper rein und was machen
sie mit den zellen so was wie ebola ist
auszuschließen und zwar deshalb weil
ebola eine ganz andere infektion macht
und vor allem sehr schnell dazu führt
dass die gesamte
blutgefäß situation die wir haben die
sind ja eine dichte unsere blutgefäße
dass die quasi undicht werden und
deswegen bluten die menschen dann sehr
schnell weil dieses virus sehr
aggressives und zellen zerstört ebola
ist infektiös aber in anführungszeichen
dass der gegenspieler dieser
infektiosität ist dass die mensch sehr
schnell symptome haben und dadurch kann
man sie sehr gut isolieren sie haben das
vielleicht gesehen gerade in afrika wo
es diese isoliert zelte gibt da kann man
wenn man schnell ist deswegen sagt mike
ryan von der whu immer man muss schnell
sein in einer pandemie recht hat er weil
wenn man es beim schafft infizierte
menschen zu isolieren kann man die virus
ausbreitung verhindern unser corona
virus hat sich einen ganz anderen
vorteil quasi erarbeitet es ist
infektiös aber ebenso mit in den ersten
zwei tagen dass man es nicht merkt dass
nach wie vor unser problem menschen kann
sich anstecken und haben überhaupt
keinen schimmer dass sie infiziert sind
und diese zwei drei tage können sie es
weiter geben und deswegen rennen wir
diesen virus immer hinterher wenn jetzt
diese strategie sich ändern müsste auf
ich bin richtig richtig infektiös und
dann werden die leute sehr schnell sehr
krank dann hätten wir so eine variante
wo die leute sich infizieren und sofort
ein paar stunden später merken dass sie
echt infiziert sind dann kann man mit
unseren maßnahmen und der wachsamkeit
solche leute schneller wieder isolieren
also ist dieses virus eher daran
interessiert
infektiöser zu sein das kann es aber nur
unbemerkt wenn es nicht so sehr krank
macht deswegen sehen wir gerade diese
strategie ob das dann da noch gilt wenn
die menschen nicht geimpft sind und
omikron infiziert werden das können wir
nicht so genau sagen weil in diesem
bericht haben sie gerade aufgehört
relativ viele menschen sind eben geimpft
und dann omikron infiziert und dann ist
es klar das ist einen leichten verlauf
hat weil wir ja ein vorbereitetes
immunsystem haben das auch omikron platt
machen kann wenn es denn infiziert daher
würde ich jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig
sagen es ist extrem unwahrscheinlich
dass sich corona so in richtung im oder
arbeiter entwickelt aber auch ich kann
nur ein bisschen in die glaskugel kurven
und immunologische virologisch überlegen
was würde ich als virus machen ich würde
eher infektiöser sein wollen als krank
machender da habe ich mehr davon und das
ist das was wir im moment sehen wir
hoffentlich bleibt es dabei ja ich sage
ich ein ganz tröstlicher gedanke dass
das virus selbst kein interesse daran
hat uns alle zu killen sondern dass wir
weiter leben sollen mit dem virus dann
halt in irgendeiner form und dagegen
versuchen uns zu wehren aber dass es
zumindest eigentlich ja in die richtung
gehen könnte dass es nicht noch
gefährlicher wird muss a93 fragt uns
über youtube welche möglichkeiten außer
der impfung können sie als professorin
noch empfehlen um das immunsystem zu
stärken sondern eine schöne frage
ja die ist ob ich gut du bist vorweg zu
sagen es gibt nicht womit man sein
immunsystem ohne impfung so gut
vorbereiten kann auf dieses corona virus
wie mit der impfung das ist einfach so
ganz viele leute fragen und schreiben
auch ich habe das immunsystem ich kenne
mein immunsystem ich finde es ja toll
dass so viele leute jetzt auf einmal ihr
immunsystem so gut kennen
das finden wir in monologen prima dass
die leute sich auf einmal dafür
interessieren aber ehrlicherweise reicht
es einfach nicht um wirklich gut auf das
virus zu reagieren das war vorher mein
fußballvergleich es ist und bleibt der
elfmeter ohne torwart wenn man nicht
geimpft ist da kann man das immunsystem
noch so gut mit vitaminen sport frischer
luft und viel schlaf sozusagen in
höchstform halten das reicht einfach
nicht es bleibt beim elfmeter ohne
torwart sie haben schon einen riesen
vorteil wenn sie ihr immunsystem nicht
schädigen weil es an sich für uns immer
da ist es arbeitet im verborgenen
kostenlos quasi immer sehr effektiv im
normalfall und man kann ist einfach sehr
gut aufrechterhalten indem man ihnen
nicht schadet und schaden würde man ihm
durch alkohol und rauchen und andere
bewusstseinserweiternde substanzen
man würde ihm schaden durch schlafentzug
das ist ja auch bei uns garten super
thema gesunde ernährung ist etwas wo man
es immer gut mit dabei hat also wenn man
eine ausgewogene ernährung hat ist es
deutlich besser als wenn man halt zum
beispiel nur fast food zu sich nimmt und
dann ist natürlich so sport ist für den
ganzen körper gut das weiß man einfach
und frische luft das ist natürlich für
das immunsystem auch prima aber es gibt
jetzt wieder nahrungsergänzungsmittel
noch sonstige kombinationen die man sich
jetzt irgendwie zu führen könnte um das
immunsystem noch besser zu machen das
ist schon echt gut aber es bleibt dabei
der elfmeter ohne torwart weil es ist
halt vorbereitet viel besser wenn es
geimpft ist dann hat es schon das team
corona ausgewähltes ist dann quasi ein
gefechts bereite einsatztruppe die gegen
das virus vorgehen kann und ansonsten
muss man streamcore ohne halt erst
zusammenstellen und es dauert ein paar
tage und es nutzt wiederum das virus
also impfen ist einfach die beste
variante sich zu schützen es bleibt
dabei
drum herum zumindest nicht wenn man also
wirklich einen guten schutz haben will
frau professor falk wir hatten
eigentlich vorgehabt mit ihnen
vielleicht bis 19 uhr zu sprechen sie
merken es gespräch zieht sich in die
länge liegt natürlich daran dass wir
immer noch auf berlin warten und da sich
noch nichts getan hat also sie geben mir
bitte ein zeichen wenn sie anderen
verpflichtungen haben und sozusagen
entlassen werden wollen von mir aber
ansonsten wir haben so viele fragen von
unseren zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir
könnten stunden lang mit ihnen
weitermachen und sind sehr dankbar dass
wir sie haben wie gesagt da müssen sie
mich jetzt aufmerksam machen wenn das
nicht mehr geht ansonsten lese ich
einfach weiter fragen vor also von mir
aus gerne aber ganz ehrlich jede chance
wo wir fragen beantworten können super
gerne weil es gibt viele fragen und wenn
wir ein bisschen dazu beitragen zu
beantworten machen wir das jetzt einfach
prima dann nehmen wir doch diese
gelegenheit gerne wahr die zocker 04
schreibt uns über youtube ich wäre für
eine impfpflicht ab 50 oder 60 die
jüngeren sind nicht relevant für die
krankenhäuser intensivstation ist das
ein richtiger gedanke eine impfpflicht
erst für ältere menschen
also ehrlich gesagt ist es kein so
toller gedanke weil das ist nicht ganz
richtig und dass es genau diese
diskussion die wir jetzt immer haben mit
der alters korrelation wer wird wirklich
schwer krank und wer nicht aus der
ersten welle da war völlig klar dass vor
allem die menschen über 60 über 70 über
80 ein höheres risiko haben schwer zu
erkranken ins krankenhaus zu müssen und
daran zu versterben gerade bei der frage
wer daran verstirbt und es nicht
überlebt sind die alten menschen
tatsächlich
die die das höchste risiko haben oder
menschen die ein eingeschränktes
immunsystem haben jetzt haben wir aber
eine phase wo wir durch die hohen
infektionszahlen einmal bei den
jugendlichen also so bis zwischen eben
zwischen den 25 jahren aber dann in der
gruppe zwischen 19 und 59 haben wir im
moment die höchsten infektionszahlen in
der gruppe der 20 bis mitte 40 jährigen
und da sind natürlich menschen dabei die
nicht nur grunderkrankungen mit wie herz
kreislauf und übergewicht und noch ein
paar andere dinge sondern die fit sind
und trotzdem ein risiko haben schwer zu
erkranken im moment haben wir sehr viele
menschen die und den 30ern in den
vierzigern sind auf intensiv ohne
vorerkrankungen wir haben vor allem und
es ist etwas was uns echt sorgen macht
schwangere frauen die sich vorher haben
nicht impfen lassen weil sie dieser
fehlinformation dass der impfstoff
irgendwas mit der fruchtbarkeit macht
oder irgendwas mit dem werden den kind
machen könnte was er gar nicht kann und
nicht macht die sich nicht haben impfen
lassen und jetzt haben wir leider immer
wieder frauen bei uns auf der
intensivstation hier drüben kann ich so
drüber über den park gucken richtung
intensivstation die schwanger sind und
auf intensiv liegen wo nicht klar ist ob
mutter und kind das überstehen werden
diese infektion und deswegen macht es
nicht so viel sinn zu sagen ab 50 haben
wir dann in pflicht weil die anderen
tragen nicht so sehr dazu bei wenn sich
entsprechend viele menschen infizieren
haben wir auch da menschen die intensiv
pflichtig werden und wenn man einmal auf
so einer intensivstation war und wir
wollen da auch immer proben ab um die zu
analysieren dann merkt man schon wie
verändert das ist wenn man da darauf
angewiesen ist dass die menschen einen
über diese krise wieder sozusagen in
gesund werden lassen und niemand geht in
so eine intensiv situation rein wie er
vorher war und kommt auf jeden fall
verändert raus weil man glaube ich diese
erfahrungen wirklich nicht machen muss
daher sind diese alters korrelationen
und groh betrachtet ja schon auch
richtig aber wenn man die einzelfälle
sieht muss man sich sagen nee also da
würde ich dann doch dafür argumentieren
dass er mit überzeugung vielleicht noch
sehr weit kommen dass wir haben eine
große hoffnung ein bisschen denke ich
mir jetzt gerade ich bin ein bisschen
ratlos was machen wir denn jetzt wenn
wir hier stark nicht jeden tag aufs
impfte sport und denkt mehr wir sind
immer noch nicht über die 75 dann wird
es wirklich ein bisschen schwierig zu
sagen wir müssen hier was tun und
deswegen fällt mir manchmal nicht mehr
so richtig ein was wir noch machen
können daher würde ich sagen
altersbezogene impfpflicht bringt glaube
ich nicht wirklich viel deswegen sollten
wir tatsächlich diskutieren ob wir eine
brauchen mir persönlich wäre es lieber
wenn wir keine bräuchten nur langsam
gehen und so sind die argumente aus und
die zeit läuft uns davon
gesagt haben würde ja in der tat für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht sprechen die
ja nun soweit man das beurteilen kann
auch von einer mehrheit in der politik
inzwischen
befürwortet wird
das über youtube fragt uns aus welchem
grund es gibt ein bisschen in die
gleiche richtung sollen kinder geimpft
werden wenn bekannt ist dass diese doch
nur sehr sehr sehr selten schwer an
corona erkranken vielleicht das ist eine
immer wieder gestellte frage vielleicht
haben sie dazu auch noch mal was sagen
genau das hat eigentlich die deutsche
gesellschaft für kinder und
jugendmedizin hat ganz gut
herausgearbeitet ist dass wir drei
argumentationslinien gibt für die frage
kinder impfen und wenn ja warum und wie
würde man argumentieren der punkt den
sie gerade genannt haben es natürlich
ganz klar es geht gar nicht dass kinder
geimpft werden sollen weil es erwachsene
gibt die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
und wir sagen wir brauchen eine höhere
impfquote also erreichen wir die über
die kinder das ist ein argument das
würde niemand so auch wirklich weiter
argumentieren die stiko äußert sich ja
auch ganz klar diese kurze stellungnahme
heute auf der webseite der steg kurstadt
unten drin es ist natürlich so dass auch
gar keinen fall eine kinder impfung in
betracht gezogen werden darf weil die
erwachsenen nicht geimpft sind und weil
man dazu dass wir da die dazu nehmen
möchte das pandemie bestehen einzufangen
das ist also eine ganz klare linie die
ich auch sofort genau so sehen würde und
die kinder und jugendmedizin sieht das
auch so die zweite frage ist haben wir
vorhin schon kurz besprochen ich traue
diesem virus nicht über den weg leichte
verläufe ist ja zumindest schon mal so
weit so gut dass die kinder in der regel
nicht schwer krank werden es gibt aber
auch kinder die eben grunderkrankungen
haben also nicht nur diese trisomie 21
das down-syndrom sondern auch herz
kreislauf erkrankungen sind gerade ein
punkt auch übergewicht und diabetes bei
kindern zum beispiel es gibt herzfehler
bei kindern also durch ein breites
spektrum von erkrankungen diese kinder
hätten definitiv ein höheres risiko wenn
sie denn sich mit corona infizieren die
sollen jetzt auch auf 5 geimpft werden
dürfen nach der stiko aussage das macht
total sind und dann hat man sozusagen
noch die frage na gut wenn bei gesunden
kindern der impfeffekt jetzt nicht so
stark weil die nicht so schwer krank
werden dann gibt es noch einen ganz
breiten aspekt und das ist das soziale
umfeld und das sagen auch die kinder-
und jugendmediziner schule und kita ist
natürlich sehr viel mehr als die zeit in
der schule und in der kita bei das sind
ja die gruppen von freundinnen und
freunden wo die kinder sich entwickeln
und wo sie auch ihren sozialen ausgleich
und ihre soziale komponente finden und
das zu ermöglichen ist ein sehr sehr
wichtiger aspekt und wenn man schule
kita und gemeinsames erleben möglich
machen kann dadurch dass man eine höhere
impfung hat bei den kindern und eben
nicht schulen schließen muss und schon
garnicht kitas dann hat man da in den
sozialen aspekt den man mit
berücksichtigen sollte dieser aspekt ist
aber jetzt nicht das was in der
aufgabenbeschreibung der stiko steht die
stiko kümmert sich um den körper eines
menschen eines kindes und bewertet die
risiko nutzen abwägung für diesen körper
und für die gesundheit der jeweiligen
person die gesellschaftliche seite und
diese ganze soziale seite ist nicht die
aufgabe der stiko das ist aber unser
aller aufgabe in der bewertung wie würde
man dann die impfung für kinder
argumentieren und da finde ich diese
gesellschaft für kinder und
jugendmedizin sehr gut wenn die sagen es
ist ein sehr hohes ziel und ein
wichtiges ziel kinder kindern die schule
und die kita zu ermöglichen wenn man das
besser kann mit der impfung weil man
kollektiven schutz erreicht dann ist das
durchaus etwas was für die impfung
spricht und so würde ich im moment auch
argumentieren
jetzt erreicht uns die frage von jessica
rogers über youtube geht auch noch um
kinder und jugendlichen die zahl der
inzidenz bei ihnen ist enorm wir wissen
nicht was für folgen auch nach jahren
eine infektion nach sich zieht warum
gibt es keine vorgezogenen weihnachts
für die frage
das ist irgendwie die politische
umsetzung das ist genau so zu sagen sie
teilen meine wie soll ich sagen mein
misstrauen gegenüber dem virus dass wir
eben nicht wissen was es langfristig
heißt deswegen würde ich kinder gerne
schützen wie man jetzt das umsetzt indem
man die schulen früher schließt das ist
wieder die politische seite und das
haben wir ganz oft gesehen wie ihr
wissenschaftler und rinnen argumentieren
aufgrund unserer expertise mal
immunologisch mal virologisch maleki dem
biologisch mal aus der modell ihrer
seite die umsetzung der politik hat noch
viele andere dinge die sie mit beachten
muss das habe ich auch gelernt in diesen
letzten monaten und da ist es
tatsächlich so dass zum einen schule
möglich machen ja sehr viel mehr ist als
schule für die kinder das heißt vor
allem für die erwachsenen wie
organisiere ich meinen alltag das ist
ein sie alle sehr viel besser als ich
also da ist dann noch mal die frage
können wir das jetzt auch umsetzen oder
haben wir dann wieder einen ziemlichen
stressfaktor auch die familien das
möchte man nicht unbedingt haben und ich
habe glaube mein eindruck ist so ein
bisschen dass deshalb die politik noch
so unklar ist was aber auch nicht hilft
weil sie früher man solche mal was damit
man ankündigte besser kann sich
natürlich eine familie darauf einsteigen
ich bin der vollkommen bei ihnen beim
manchmal hat man das gefühl dass die
politik nicht so ganz klar ist was die
umsetzung bedeutet an vielen stellen und
dann wird dann was empfohlen oder auf
den weg gebracht und die umsetzung ist
dann so nicht so ganz elegant ein
bisschen vorlauf geholfen hätte so
ähnlich kommt es mir jetzt auch wieder
vor ich habe den eindruck dass man gerne
versuchen möchte nicht früher
weihnachtsferien zu machen aus eben
diesen gründen mit wer kann dann wie zur
arbeit und wie machen wir das aber
trotzdem haben wir steigende zahlen bei
den kindern und dieses
kräftegleichgewicht sozusagen es im
moment noch nicht so nur zu einer
entscheidung kommt vielleicht wenn jetzt
dann doch irgendwann diese vier stühle
man die personen gefüllt werden
vielleicht hören wir dazu was könnte ja
durchaus sein
denn falls beobachten und warten auch
gespannt darauf wie fragt uns über
youtube sollten auch dreifach geimpfte
über die feiertage ihre kontakte
reduzieren oder ist der iba spiegelt so
hoch dass es sehr unwahrscheinlich ist
infiziert zu werden oder das virus
weiter zu gehen jetzt müssten sie
vielleicht gerade noch mal kurz erklären
spiegel was ist damit gemeint genau ich
bin begeistert da kennt sich jemand mit
ihr spiegeln aus einmal kurz noch zu
erklären wenn wir über diese antikörper
reden dann haben wir verschiedene
antikörper klassen im körper und das
sind auch so details die einen sonst
nicht interessieren jetzt auf einmal
wird es spannend zu sagen wenn wir im
blut antikörper messen dann messen wir
meistens diese sogenannten ige
antikörper spiegelt das sind jemand
generell so im blut hat wir brauchen
aber zur virus abwehr eigentlich quasi
sozusagen das mobile einsatzteam hier
oben im nasen-rachen-raum als
abfangjäger ich bezeichne thema als
abfangjäger das sind die die von
vornherein verhindern können dass uns
virus infiziert und in den schleimhäuten
sitzt das sogenannte iba das ist
sozusagen der antikörper der hat immer
noch die gleiche erkennungs struktur was
er den binden kann nämlich das bike hat
aber dann an der rückseite sozusagen
eine andere kette und diese kette kann
sich am besten in den schleimhäuten
verankern und deswegen sitzen diese ige
antikörper generell an schleimhäuten
mund nase indem die sind super geeignet
für die abwehr von allem was eben über
die schleimhäute in unseren körper zu
kommen versucht diese idee a spiegelt
die können wir im blut messen weil die
sind sozusagen über das blut wandern die
dann in die schleimhäute die sind aber
relativ schnell weg quasi hier in die
schleimhäute gehen deswegen ist das
messen der ikea spiegel immer so ein
bisschen über den daumen gepeilt sagt es
uns aha wir haben ideal schon ein guter
start das geht wahrscheinlich in die
schleimhäute da soll es ja auch hin aber
es sagt uns nicht genau wie viel
wirklich hier sitzt und das ist
eigentlich unser problem wir können hier
im nasen-rachen-raum ihr nicht messen
wie viel antikörper haben wir denn hier
und wieviel abfangjäger haben wir
postiert deswegen müssen wir im blut und
hoffen dann dass es so einigermaßen
passt zu dem was wohl auch in der nase
und im rachen sitzen wird aber genau
wissen wir es nicht das ist sozusagen
die erklärung warum ist ikea zwar
interessant zu wissen aber wir können
nicht genau sagen wie es hier oben in
der nase und im rachen aussieht ja es
hilft in dieser situation immer wenn wir
auch mit drei impfungen darüber
nachdenken wo gehe ich hin wen treffe
ich da und habe ich möglichst keine
leute die in risiko haben das beispiel
ist familie um ihr und opi besuchen wäre
meine empfehlung antiken schnelltest
sind viel besser als ihr ruf wenn man
sie richtig macht egal was auf der
packung steht man kann immer erst in den
rachen und dann in die nase gehen dann
hat man nämlich alle möglichen
flächenlose und virus sitzen könnte
schon mal abgeschrubbt und dann soll
anti den schnelltest und wenn der
negativ ist hat man zumindest schon mal
die sicherheit dass man nicht infektiös
ist aber man muss schon ordentlich
machen also wirklich hierher um kratzen
und ein bisschen von der schleimhaut
abkratzen sonst bringt nichts das wäre
zum beispiel die eine geschichte die
andere ist großveranstaltungen
da muss ich sagen solange wir nicht
wissen die omikron wirklich hier so
zirkuliert sind großveranstaltungen
etwas was ja sowieso im moment nicht
wirklich erlaubt ist und ich würde
einfach nicht machen weil selbst wenn
man drei mal geimpft ist und
wahrscheinlich ein sehr sehr sehr
geringes risiko hat es ist einfach so
enge kontakte dirk brockmann hat gerade
gesagt können einfach dazu führen das
virus überspringt und man muss sich ja
nicht permanent sozusagen herausfordern
wie weit man wirklich geschützt wäre
wenn man kontakt hätte deswegen würde
ich vorsichtig sagen mit bedacht
überlegen wie man unter welchen
bedingungen trifft und idealerweise
öfter mal ein antigen stellt fest zu
machen das machen wir hier ja auch das
wäre so eine art 3g plus wenn es sinn
macht vorsichtig ohne jetzt da vorgaben
zu machen aber ich besuch zum beispiel
in heidelberg das habe ich ganz fest vor
meine besten freundinnen die sind schon
in richtung 80 unterwegs und natürlich
machen wir das so dass wir in vielen
antiken schnelltest machen damit wir
einfach sicher sind die sind alle beide
3g im tram erkämpft aber dass wir da
einfach nichts mitschleppen das fühlt
sich immer besser an und so würde ich
versuchen die weihnachtszeit einfach mit
so ein bisschen nachdenken zu gestalten
ist meistens nicht verkehrt lg hat sie
bei youtube was machen menschen die sich
wegen einer allergie nicht impfen lassen
können alternative tod impfstoff
fragezeichen es gibt zu wenig aufklärung
für menschen mit allergien bitte
beantworten
das ist eigentlich ganz einfache antwort
weil es gibt nur eine einzige allergie
die wirklich gegen eine impfung spricht
und das ist die allergie gegen
polyethylen glykol pg das war er von ihr
angesprochen sorge das hatte ich
unterschlagen pge genau das ist
tatsächlich die einzige allergie alles
andere haselnuss erdbeeren karotten was
auch immer nickel das sind alles dinge
die nicht relevant sind für die mpg ist
es in der tat gibt wenige menschen die
so eine pg allergie haben und das ist
jetzt so die mrsa und die vor allem die
em-arena impfstoffe sind ja verpackt in
diese kleinen tröpfchen und da ist einer
der bestandteile ist tatsächlich dieses
polyethylenglykol
deswegen sind die nicht geeignet weil
das sind die hoch allergiker gegen
diesen einen stoff ich habe jetzt mal
nachgeguckt bei
bei dem nowaks im gestopft das ist das
protein eiweiß das bike schon als
fertiges protein also nicht der bauplan
sondern es ist so viele tot impfstoff
nur das richtig verstehen der jetzt
genau das ist nur das bike als protein
fertig gefaltet da gibt es einen zusatz
der eine gewisse ähnlichkeit hat mit dem
tg deswegen sollte man da noch mal
tatsächlich mit einem allergologen
sprechen wie hoch das risiko wäre mit
nowaks diese substanzen sind von der
struktur her ein bisschen anders aber es
gibt berichte dass es da auch da meine
mögliche kreuz
aktivität zu dieser pg allergie geben
könnte das ist bei mode nutzer wachstum
das problem die anderen tod stoffe wie
zb bei newa das ist ja erst gesamte
virus wo man erst in der zellkultur das
virus produziert und ist dann in
aktiviert und das ist auch ein stoff
profil aktoren heißt es zeug damit kann
man diese viren in aktivieren so dass
die zwar noch alle proteine haben aber
nicht mehr aktiv sind also quasi ein
mausetot des virus sozusagen und diese
tod impfstoffe die haben auch substanzen
dabei die ein bisschen ähnlich sind auch
da würde ich mit den allergologen
nochmal rücksprache halten wie stark die
allergie tatsächlich ist
wahrscheinlich haben die einfachen
weniger allergische komponente dabei als
die ma impfstoffe gerade eben
möglicherweise der navax impfstoff aber
so ganz ohne es ist nicht das sollte man
tatsächlich besprechen ob wie wie man
auch dass dieses allergie geschehen
monitoren kann die meisten allergiker
die sowas haben wissen ja sehr genau wie
der körper reagiert und dass man auch
mit antihistaminika mit steroiden also
mit kortison das sehr gut einfangen kann
wenn man rechtzeitig weiß das ist echt
eine sehr individuelle knifflige frage
aber im moment würde ich ganz vorsichtig
macht mich noch mal mit wachs also dem
tod impfstoffen aus dem protein
beschäftigen und dann nochmal
rücksprache halten ob das vielleicht
eine alternative wäre gut dann haben wir
noch eine frage per mail von martin
wagemann er sagt gute und verständliche
darstellung von der frau professorin
also auch da noch mal großes lob an sie
meine frage wie soll eine frau in der
schwangerschaft mit einer ausstehenden
dritten impfung umgehen also impfung
schwangerschaft wie verhält sich das
da ist es auch so es gibt ja eine
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
dass in den ersten drei monaten die
empfehlung nicht unbedingt für eine
impfung spricht sondern erst dann ab dem
vierten monat und dran geimpft werden
kann wenn es so ist dass die ersten
beiden impfungen vorher waren dann die
schwangerschaft eingetreten ist dann
würde man einmal sagen es macht schon
sinn diese drei monate und er
möglicherweise nicht dann zu impfen und
diese drei monate abzuwarten und auf dem
vierten monat zu impfen ich persönlich
würde in so einem fall einfach nochmal
doch ausnahmsweise die antikörper
bestimmen lassen bei das ist schon
richtig dass so eine generelle
antikörper bestimmung in der
gesamtbevölkerung jetzt nichts bringen
würde es ein tierischer aufwand sehr
teuer und wir stünden dann damit lauter
antikörper spiegeln wo man sich fragt
reicht es reicht es nicht das bringt nix
in so einem fall ist es machen wir es
trotzdem wäre meine idee dass trotzdem
zu machen machen wir auch mit anderen
patientengruppen wenn man wissen möchte
ist überhaupt noch was weil wir nämlich
wirklich so ganz wenig da es war so eine
schwangerschaft ist ja sozusagen ein
sehr einzigartiger zustand weil ja die
zellen des väterlichen körper in den
körper der mutter sich mit entstehen in
diesem fotos und da muss der körper der
frau eine art toleranz entwickelnde
immunologische toleranz für das neue
entstehende leben damit es nicht
abgestoßen wird und dieses toleranz
geschehen ist ein teil der
schwangerschaft immunologisch und in so
einer situation sich mit irgendwas
anzustecken ist man keine gute idee weil
ja die toleranz sozusagen dann auch
gegen ein mögliches virus zum beispiel
entschwindet deswegen keine gute idee
sich anzustecken und in dieser phase
dann zu impfen würde unter umständen
auch heißen dass vielleicht der erfolg
nicht so groß ist deswegen ist die
schwangerschaft auch immunologisch
gesehen total faszinierend weil es ja
das werdende leben muss geschützt werden
das macht das immunsystem auch kommt
aber natürlich auch immer mit so ein
bisschen ein beschränkten immunabwehr
daher und deswegen ist es so dass man
sich sagen würde wenn antikörper da sind
und diese ersten drei monate noch nicht
vorbei sind kann man vielleicht noch
warten aber danach würde man doch auch
wieder die dritte impfung angehen so
ungefähr würde man das ganz vorsichtig
mai so argumentieren wunderbar also das
jetzt zum thema schwangerschaft das
vielleicht jetzt nicht für alle von
interesse aber das thema maske schon
thomas wüst fragt uns nämlich soll man
jetzt ffp zwei masken tragen da man noch
nicht so viel über omikron weiß oder
reichen herkömmliche op masken aus was
ihr kollege schmidt chanasit gestern ja
verlautbart hat das habe ich jetzt nicht
mitbekommen aber ist ja die frage ob
tatsächlich ffp zwei masken und op
masken da annähernd gleichwertig
funktionieren das kommt drauf an wo sie
hingehen ich gebe ihnen mal ein beispiel
ich habe kein auto und deswegen fahre
ich fahrrad und werden zwar nicht reicht
und vielleicht zug
überfüllte züge sind im moment echt so
ein thema weil ich mir denke da ist
irgendwie
irgendwas zwischen 0 und 3 g
wahrscheinlich und in dem zug würde ich
mir im moment immer eine ft2 maske
aufsetzen weil es einfach ein
geschlossener raum ist in diesem zug es
sind meistens doch viele menschen drin
und da ist die effekte 2 auf jeden fall
eine sehr gute idee weil das wird alles
mögliche rum und deswegen würde ich das
so immer machen wenn man aber jetzt zum
beispiel im alltag ist und man geht
einkaufen und vielleicht nicht gerade zu
den rush hour zeiten dann kann man wenn
man weiß dass man irgendwo reingeht wo
man einen großen raum hat und nicht so
viele menschen sind dann ist mit
sicherheit auch eine normale
medizinische maske ausreichend weil es
kommt immer auf die dichte an mit dem
man menschen nahe kommt und wieviel
virus wahrscheinlich in einem raum sie
kennen das alle wenn sie irgendwo der
sitzung hatten und die ganze luft ist
verbraucht und dann kommen sie daran und
sie merken schon die luft steht einfach
dann weiß man einfach da hätte
theoretisch wenn da ein mensch infiziert
wäre hat man die möglichkeit dass man
sich ansteckt das sind andere situation
da ziehe ich dann gerne meine ffp zwei
aus der tasche weil ich mir denke so ein
hörsaal wir sind jetzt etwa nur halb
besetzt oder nur ein drittel besetzt
aber das ist ein raum für mich wo ich
denke dass mit der luftzirkulation ist
so eine sache da setze ich meine fb2
maske auch also man kann sich selber so
ein bisschen überlegen wie viel luft wie
viel frischluft habe ich wie viele
kontakte habe ich und die faustregel ist
einfach je mehr menschen länger in einem
geschlossenen raum womöglich noch dann
macht die ffw zwei total sinn und dann
kann man wir machen das hier den ganzen
tag maske auf maske runter das ist halt
etwas das kann man sich ja auch so ein
bisschen an gewöhnen dass man
situationsabhängig mal die eine auszieht
mal die andere und den geschlossenen
räumen hätte ich noch den tipp das haben
wir auch gemacht alle büros bei uns
haben co2 messgerät das ist total cool
weil man sieht sofort wenn man lange
nicht gelüftet hat dann geht der co2
wert hoch dann lüftet man automatisch
und dann hat man eine sehr zuverlässige
aber auch ganz niedrigschwellige
sozusagen eine anregung dass man lüftet
und dass man versucht hier einfach immer
eine sehr gute luftzirkulation zu haben
dass er noch so ein tipp am rande
nicht unwichtig das noch mal zu
beherzigen wir haben gerade die
information bekommen dass es gegen 20
uhr losgehen soll mit der
pressekonferenz ich mach jetzt aber mal
folgenden vorschlag dass wir jedenfalls
nicht länger als bis 20 untereinander
reden jetzt schon ein schlechtes
gewissen dass sie so lange hier in
anspruch nehmen aber es ist natürlich
auch wahnsinnig informativ und wir
kriegen eben auch viele zuschriften und
die fragen an sie sind sehr sehr
zahlreich vielleicht weil wir gerade
über die massen gesprochen haben ja was
glauben sie denn eigentlich wie lange
wird das noch zu unserem alltag gehören
das ist natürlich jetzt auch noch mal
der blick in die glaskugel man hat
früher immer andere teile der welt so
ein bisschen belächelt weil da schon
sowieso fleißig maske getragen wurde in
fernost zum beispiel wird das auch über
jahre bei uns normalität werden was
glauben sie
also es ist gerade im moment der
wochenbericht mein lieblingsgericht vom
rk ii rausgekommen und da sieht man als
erste abbildung ist so eine heatmap das
ist so eine farbskala die geht von blau
niedriger instanzen leider im moment auf
dem rotor inzidenz wenn man diese
farbskala anschaut dann sieht man in der
mitte einen blauen see das sind die
niedrigen in sidenten die wir haben ab
mai juni juli august im sommer
saisonales virus und in diesen zeiten da
ist es einfach so wir haben dann
hoffentlich nächstes jahr wieder ab
früher niedrige incidents professor ich
muss sie unterbrechen wir sehen den
bundeskanzler wo sodass man fernsieht
sehr cool findet es war auch sehr cool
dass ich solche mit uns gesprochen haben
ich danke ihnen jetzt schon mal ganz
herzlich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
abend falsche uns nachher nicht mehr
sprechen genau dankeschön für ihre
ausführung und wir hören den
bundeskanzler dankeschön frau professor
falls wir gehen rüber nach belieben
ist der präsidentin höchst und den
berliner regierenden bürgermeister
müller und herr scholz beginnt
einen schönen guten abend von meiner
seite aus wir haben
heute eine sehr
intensive ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gehabt die zugleich die erste
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zusammen
mit der neuen regierung und dem neuen
bundeskanzler war es war eine sehr
konstruktive beratung und damit aus
meiner sicht auch ein sehr guter auftakt
für die zusammenarbeit der nächsten
jahre das haben eine ganze reihe von
themen hier eine rolle gespielt die
normales tagesgeschäft sind und die
nicht alle von dramatischer bedeutung
sind im mittelpunkt unserer beratung
stand aber natürlich die frage wie wir
weiter umgehen mit den herausforderungen
die die korona pandemie und stellt klar
ist dass wir gerade jetzt dabei sind die
beschlüsse der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz umzusetzen
wo wir in der konferenz und festgelegt
haben eine ganze reihe von gesetzlichen
änderungen auf den weg zu bringen die
dazu beitragen sollen dass die länder
ein ausreichend gutes und starkes
handlungs instrumentarium zur verfügung
haben die gesetzgebung findet diese
woche statt auch das war ein ergebnis
der letzten beratung es hat eine
sondersitzung des deutschen bundestages
gegeben wir haben gerade heute intensive
beratungen in dem
bundestag gehabt und morgen soll dann
abschließend entschieden werden und auch
der bundesrat zu einem eigenen beitrag
leisten so dass wir in unglaublich
kurzer zeit den gesetzlichen rahmen
geschaffen wir brauchen das ist
vielleicht auch eine grundlage für das
was wir an zusammenarbeit und für die
nächste zeit vornehmen wir wollen
schnell handeln entschlossen handeln
wenn es notwendig ist und das gelingt in
enger kooperation zwischen bund und
ländern wenn alle das wollen und alle
sich das miteinander vornehmen
das was unsere größte herausforderung
jetzt darstellt ist und bleibt wie wir
es hinbekommen dass möglichst viele
bürger und bürger sich jetzt impfen
lassen und
sich eine auffrischungsimpfung holen aus
allem was wir wissen auch von den
veränderungen im virus geschehen kann
man den schluss ziehen dass es umso
dringender ist dass jetzt möglichst
viele eine auffrischungsimpfung bekommen
und das ist deshalb gut dass wir auch
miteinander noch einmal alle
anstrengungen unternehmen dafür zu
sorgen dass neben den hausärztinnen
hausärzte und vielen anderen auch
gleichzeitig neue impf angebote in
impfzentren gemacht werden mit einem
mobilen impf teams damit wir das
ehrgeizige ziel erreichen
beginnt von dem zeitpunkt an wo die
impfung aller erwachsenen möglich
gewesen ist auch tatsächlich 30
millionen impfung zu erreichen erst
empfang und auffrischungsimpfung
zusammen das ist glaube ich ein ganz
ganz wichtiger punkt den wir hier
nochmal sehr sorgfältig besprochen haben
es ist gleichzeitig festgelegt worden
dass wir all das was
wir vorhaben auch jetzt in der nächsten
woche
aktivieren der krisenstab ist schon
aktiven aktiv mit general bayer der
intensive arbeit leisten abstimmung mit
allen dingen die verantwortung haben und
eine sitzung des krisenstabs mit dem
verantwortlichen zb in ländern sollen
die kommende woche stattfinden
dort wird dann relevant festgelegt was
alles zu tun ist um die impfkampagne
weiter zu unterstützen das gilt im
übrigen auch im hinblick auf die enge
kooperation mit dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium und der
gemeinsamen anstrengung dafür sorge zu
tragen dass wir genau die imf logistik
verstehen müssen die für impfstoff wir
waren zu welcher zeit zur verfügung
haben und wie wir es herstellen können
dass das auch im nächsten jahr
fortgesetzt werden kann
gleichzeitig wollen wir die lage immer
aktuell beobachten und dann auch mit
ganz ganz schnell entscheidungen treffen
deshalb wird auch der expertenrat jetzt
zusammentreten dass es vorbereitet
worden bereits vor der wahl des neuen
kanzlers
in dieser woche so dass das auch jetzt
zügig gleich nächste woche geschehen
kann dort erwarten wir uns abschläge
miteinander dort besprochen ratschläge
für unsere eigene arbeit und wird aus
all den erkenntnissen die wir da
erziehen jeweils ein dringender
handlungsbedarf entsteht der auch eine
neue zusammenkunft zb der
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidenten
mit der bundesregierung zur konsequenz
hat dann werden wir das auch tun auch
das haben wir hier verabredet wir werden
also nicht warten sondern schnell
zusammenkommen sobald etwas zu
entscheiden ist
vielleicht noch einen hinweis auf ein
thema das uns auch bewegt hat die frage
wie wir stärker noch gegen hass und
hetze let's vorgehen können da sind ja
eine ganze reihe von verrohung zu
beobachten es gibt jetzt schon eine sehr
entschiedene gesetzgebung aber jetzt
besteht der wunsch noch einmal gemeinsam
zu schauen wie man ganz gezielt
sicherstellen kann dass auch kein
netzwerk
betrachtet bleibt und das ist von den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten nochmals wunsch an
die regierung herangetreten worden und
der justizminister hat gesagt da besteht
großes interesse dass auch jetzt schnell
zu machen denn tatsächlich wird es so
sein dass das ja auch auf basis der
verständigung der künftigen regierung
ohnehin eine aufgabe ist also gute
beratung zur wohnanlage der wille der
gemeinsame bilder schnell entschlossen
zu handeln eine gemeinsame
fahrt wie wir uns das notwendige wissen
über all das was wir entscheiden auch
jeweils erarbeiten um das dann auch
zügig tun zu können und ein guter
ausgangspunkt für all die großen
anstrengungen die wir jetzt noch vor uns
haben
dann als nächstes erwischt vielen dank
auch an dieser stelle möchte ich noch
einmal ganz herzlich zur gestrigen wahl
zum bundeskanzler in unserer besucher
stand ganz herzlich gratulieren habe das
geld persönlich gemacht und heute auch
noch mal im namen der länder die
amtsantritt fällen eine überaus
herausfordernde zeit es geht um den
zusammenhang der gesellschaft das thema
klimawandel versöhnen mit
industriestandort um natürlich der
fordernde kampf gegen die pandemie wir
wünschen dir alles ganz ganz viel erfolg
dafür der bundespräsident hat gestern
gesagt die menschen hoffen darauf dass
sie führung zeigen und gemeinsam mit den
ländern die notwendigen maßnahmen
treffen
dem stimme ich ausdrücklich zu genau
darauf kommt es an jetzt vertrauensvoll
und sachorientiert gemeinsam politik zu
machen klarheit konsistentes handeln und
verlässlichkeit wir sind immer dann
stark in krisen wenn alle staatlichen
ebenen gemeinsam agieren und deshalb
bieten die länder den bundeskanzler
insbesondere in dieser zeit eine
konstruktive zusammenarbeit zum wohl der
menschen in unserem land an es ist ein
gutes signal in diesem sinne ist einen
tag nachdem die neue bundesregierung ins
amt gekommen ist ganz der
bundesregierung teilgenommen hat so sie
im lande war und sehr ausgiebig zeit
hatte im stoff war über die
entscheidenden punkte heute zu
diskutieren und nach den ganzen
sondersitzungen der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz war es ja
jetzt eine regel konferenz insofern gab
es eben auch eine vielzahl anderer
themen natürlich das wichtigste thema
trotzdem die infektions lage in
deutschland sie es ernst sie ist in
einigen teilen des landes dramatisch in
der anhörung des hauptausschusses im
bundestag am gestrigen tage ist von
experten noch mal zweifel geäußert
worden ob die bestehenden maßnahmen
ausreichen wenn sich die omikron
variante weiter
verbreitet und es ist gut dass die
regierung tragenden fraktionen ihre
bereitschaft erklärt haben das
infektionsschutzgesetz
nachzubessern und den ländern mehr
möglichkeiten zu geben die menschen zu
schützen das ist ein schritt in die
richtige richtung die nicht anerkennen
möchte aber es gibt eben diese zweifel
ob diese nachbesserungen
ausreichen wir müssen die dynamik des
infektionsgeschehen weiter im blick
haben vorsicht wachsamkeit
voraussicht bleiben das gebot der stunde
wir müssen das fernlicht nutzen und
nicht nur auf sicht fahren wichtig ist
den ländern auch dass die verabredete
einrichtungs bezogene im pflicht zum
schutz besonders
schutzbedürftiger gruppen in
pflegeheimen insbesondere schnell
umgesetzt werden wir brauchen diese
wirkung zum schutz dieser menschen so
früh wie möglich und auch der zeitplan
für die beratung und einführung einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht darf sich nicht
verzögern gerade wegen der vierten welle
brauchen sie tempo um vor allem ältere
menschen zu schützen das impfen ist und
bleibt die stärkste waffe im kampf gegen
das virus und deshalb ist es gut und ich
bin dankbar dafür dass der neue
gesundheitsminister heute festgestellt
hat dass wir das ziel 30 millionen
impfdosen bis jahresende genug impfstoff
zur verfügung steht wir sehen dass
überall in den ländern die in floristik
ist deutlich hochgefahren worden ja es
hat an der einen stelle geruckelt aber
ich kann sagen in nordrhein westfalen
bei 1,4 millionen impfungen geschafft in
der letzten woche das ist so viel wie
nie zuvor zu hoch zeit der impfkampagne
im sommer mit den großen zentralen
impfzentren haben wir 1,1 millionen
geschafft und der ausbau der
infrastruktur ist noch nicht
abgeschlossen die länder werden jetzt
gemeinsam im bund länder krisenstab ihre
fähigkeiten einbringen zur verfügung
stehen für die umsetzung steht kein
politisches entscheidungsgremium zum
thema im logistik monitoring- und
ähnliche fragen daran wirken die länder
gerne mit ein punkt der mir besonders
wichtig ist er mir am herzen liegt ist
eine zwischen bund und ländern
abgestimmte medikamenten strategie das
kann eine zweite säule sei neben dem
impfen um besonders schwere
krankheitsverläufe und schlimmes leid
aber natürlich auch die überlastung der
intensivstationen zu verhindern dazu
können medikamente einen guten beitrag
leisten das hat auch herr minister
lauterbach heute bestätigt es kommen
immer mehr medikamente in die zulassung
auch auf dem markt jetzt schon und auch
in nächster zukunft entscheidend ist
dabei immer dass frühe behandlung
erfolgt nicht erst wenn die menschen mit
atemnot zum arzt gehen deswegen mussten
wir müssen wir ein stück
aufklärungsarbeit
leistung war eine gemeinsame strategie
der beschaffung das ganz schnell direkt
nach einem positiven test die
medikamente an patienten sind natürlich
tempo bei zulassung und wo nötig auch
noch gezielte förderung der nationalen
titel forschung wie wir sie in nordrhein
westfalen machen wichtiger punkt heute
der allen wichtig war entlastung des
pflegepersonals
wir haben hier bei der sonder antic am
18 november den wunsch nach einem pflege
bonus zum ausdruck gebracht
bundeskanzler hat heute zugesagt dass er
schnell kommen soll ist eine wichtige
anerkennung für die menschen die
großartiges leisten für uns alle in
dieser schwierigen zeit ein weiteres
thema ist konzentriert nämlich die
entlastung für die krankenhäuser dass es
da dort eine regelung gefunden wird die
über den 31 dezember hinaus verlängert
wird bis zum märz die bundesregierung
sich heute committed dafür sind wir
dankbar wir haben einen beschluss
gefasst zum thema kinder und junge leute
kinder und junge leute haben in der
pandemie sehr gelitten manches ist
nichts wieder aufzuholen was da versäumt
worden ist uns eine wichtige aufgabe
diese personengruppe kinder und junge
leute in besonderer weise in den blick
zu nehmen
bund und länder haben gemeinsam schon
viel geld in die hand genommen und es
wird wichtig sein das ziel gesetzt um zu
richten dass kinder und junge leute
nicht noch mehr leiden und da die die
pandemie wir begrüßen unisono die
heutige aussage der ständigen
impfkommission zu impfungen für kinder
mit vorerkrankungen im alter zwischen
fünf und elf die länder zuständig
kinderärzte werden das impfangebot dafür
sicherstellen darauf können sich die
menschen verlassen will den beschluss zu
hass und hetze in den
kommunikationsdiensten ausdrücklich
unterstreichen wir sehen dass diese
pandemie den zusammenhalt in unserer
gesellschaft heraus fordert deshalb sind
wir einig sind bestürzt wir sind auch
ein stück entsetzt über
ausmaß von hass und hetze in den
vergangenen monaten der nicht weniger
sondern mehr wird wie erklären unsere
solidarität und uneingeschränkte
unterstützung mit den betroffenen von
drohungen von fackel umzügen und all
diesen dingen es ist indiskutabel was da
passiert dieser haft dieser hass trifft
insbesondere diejenigen die vor ort
repräsentanten unserer demokratie sind
bürgermeisterin bürgermeister bis hin zu
amtsleitern die nicht mehr unbescholten
leben können vor ort wir sehen mit
großer sorge was da an
verschwörungstheorien anlügen an hetze
an viele informationen über ganz
bestimmte kommunikations plattformen
verbreitet wird und
auch ein großes publikum
erreicht unsere freiheitlich-
demokratische gesellschaft basiert
darauf dass wir uns frei austauschen
können aber rechtsverstöße müssen auch
konsequent geahndet werden eben auch im
digitalen bereich die wären da sind sich
das hat eigentlich das kommunikations
plattformen mit öffentlichen gruppen
eine angemessene regulierung im netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz wir dürfen und ich
bin auch führen die zusage diesbezüglich
dankbar gemeinsam mit unseren
innenministern haben wir die bitte
geäußert dahingehend unklarheiten zu
beseitigen und zu prüfen wie straftaten
dort im bereich von hass und hetze
konsequent geahndet werden können unsere
demokratie muss wehrhaft bleiben auch in
digitalen polarisierung und spaltung
dürfen keine chance haben bund und
länder leisten für den zusammenhalt in
unserer gesellschaft ihren beitrag indem
sie bei der pandemie bekämpfung
entschlossen an einem strang ziehen die
tun das auch über den regierungswechsel
hinaus deshalb noch einmal ganz
herzlichen dank für die guten heutigen
beratung an sicher bundeskanzler und
ihre gesamte regierung
dann als drittes der regierende
bürgermeister von wellen
vielen dank auch ich möchte betonen dass
es sehr gute und konstruktive beratungen
heute waren auch mal mit einem größeren
themenkatalog wir das auch mal
beispielhaft benennen dass der einsatz
der europäischen mittel auch nach der
praxis entscheidung eine rolle gespielt
hat heute ist natürlich auch für uns in
den ländern sehr wichtig wie es da
weitergeht die ausgaben für forschung
und entwicklung wie wir sie verstehen
oder auch ausbauen können unser drei
prozent ziel ist ja da unser maßstab
dass es eben auch wichtig um im
internationalen wettbewerb bestehen zu
können mit dem forschungs und
entwicklungs mit dem
wissenschaftsstandort deutschland oder
auch die kommission 30 jahre friedliche
revolution und damit eine
weiterentwicklung des tags der deutschen
einheit auch das hat heute eine rolle
gespielt sehr einvernehmlich haben wir
dazu auch entsprechende beschluss
entwürfe und texte verabredet also ein
größerer themen rahmen heute und dennoch
hat natürlich krone eine große rolle
gespielt ich glaube es war sehr gut zu
erleben wie die neue bundesregierung
sofort sich eben auch mit diesen so
wichtigen und den sieben dem thema
auseinandergesetzt hat ressort
übergreifend wir heute da schon auch
wieder die nächsten schritte verabreden
konnten und vor allen dingen möchte ich
hervorheben dass es wirklich sofort zu
spüren war wie der neue
bundesgesundheitsminister mit einer
tiefen fachlichen kenntnis der materie
und mit großem sachverstand schon auf
detaillierte fragen antwort geben konnte
das ist wichtig für uns es ist wichtig
für die länder gerade auch im hinblick
auf die nächsten wochen wir wissen dass
wir zu tun haben ein wichtiges ziel hat
der bundeskanzler ausgegeben die booster
impfung hochzufahren die infrastruktur
muss dafür hochgefahren werden die
entsprechenden angebote ausgebaut werden
wir tun das alles um menschen zu
schützen sagt das immer wieder
schlichtweg geht es darum menschenleben
zu retten deswegen tun wir das und wir
müssen jetzt vorbereitet sein auch auf
das was möglicherweise durch omikron
noch auf uns zukommen kann und deswegen
war es gut dass eben der
bundesgesundheitsminister auch sofort
wieder mit anderen experten aus der
wissenschaft
kontakt aufgenommen hat und da uns auch
eine perspektive nennen konnten wann wir
mit entsprechenden ergebnissen und mit
möglicherweise auch neuen erkenntnissen
rechnen können ein wichtiger wichtiger
themenkomplex konnte insofern sehr gut
und sachlich und fachlich tief beraten
werden ich möchte auch noch mal auf das
thema stiko eingehen ein großer
erleichterung glaube ich kann man sagen
für viele war es dass die stiko sich
dazu jetzt auch verhalten hat das
natürlich die kinder mit vorerkrankungen
nun auch geimpft werden können auch
diejenigen die die kinder die mit
personen in einem haushalt leben die
sehr gefährdet sein können durch eine
infektion die die kinder die er
möglicherweise hoffentlich nicht selbst
schwer erkranken aber infektion die die
kinder mitbringen den haushalt dass in
so einer situation nimmt auch die kinder
geben werden sollten und das nicht
unterschlagen
es gibt da eben auch die formulierung
dass eben auch die eben funk für kinder
bei einem individuellen wunsch möglich
sein soll das heißt bitte beratung
annehmen sich informieren rücksprache
mit den kinder ärzten erhalten wenn wir
die möglichkeit jetzt haben die kinder
auch zu impfen dort wo es möglich ist wo
in den familien das ein guter
gemeinsamer weg ist dem land verabredet
hat dann hoffe ich sehr dass sehr viele
dieses angebot auch in anspruch nehmen
und dass ich die stiko dazu jetzt
verhalten hat wenn es noch mal sagen
das war für viele eine erleichterung und
wir hoffen sehr dass wir in so einem
guten austausch mit der stiko auch
bleiben denn es ist nun mal auch für uns
eine wichtige richtschnur wir haben
mitunter länger gewartet auf empfehlung
das heute war sehr wichtig abschließend
von mir auch noch einmal zum thema hass
und hetze im netz um es klar zu sagen es
ist unerträglich und das kann dafür auch
keine entschuldigung geben für das was
sich da abspielt und jetzt kann schon
gar keine entschuldigung geben für
fackel aufmärsche vor privathäusern das
sind bilder die wir kennen aus den
zeiten aus dem dunkelsten kapitel in
unserer geschichte wo es solche fackel
aufmärsche gegeben hat und die hat es
gegeben um einzuschüchtern und das ist
offensichtlich wieder das ziel und
insofern ist es inakzeptabel und nicht
hinzunehmen und das ist auch nicht
einfach nur irgendeine
solidaritätsadresse wie wir heute
miteinander formuliert haben für herrn
kretschmer für frau kipping für andere
sondern es ist uns sehr ernst dass
gegebenenfalls hier eben auch
gesetzgeberisch mit verordnung
eingegriffen werden muss weil es so
nicht geht dass informationsplattform
für den individuellen austausch genutzt
werden für massenkommunikation und für
netzwerke die genau dieses eine ziel
haben dass ich gerade beschrieben habe
verbreiten falschmeldung bewusst zu
verbreiten bewusst angst zu schüren und
das ist gerade in dieser situation nicht
akzeptabel dass es nicht ein offener
meinungsaustausch
das ist nicht ein streit um die bessere
idee oder den besseren weg wie wir
corona und diese pandemie bekämpfen
sondern das ist ein weg der beschritten
wird um ganz andere politische ziele zu
verfolgen und insofern war ich auch sehr
froh dass wir heute parteiübergreifend
uns da sehr einig waren nicht nur
zwischen den ländern sondern auch mit
der bundesregierung und allen vertretern
und vertreterinnen der bundesregierung
dass wir hier zusammen stehen und eben
auch mit den initiativen die wir
formuliert haben gerade die auch
schützen wollen in ihrem politischen
engagement die nicht so privilegiert
sind wie wir wie die ministerpräsident
ministerpräsidenten oder minister andere
regierungsmitglieder sondern die
ehrenamtlichen vor ort sind die die in
der ersten reihe stehen und viel
aushalten müssen und die brauchen unsere
unterstützung und dass es heute ganz
deutlich geworden dass wir die auch
formulieren wollen
vielen dank jetzt kommen wir zu ihren
fragen als erstes michael fischer von
dpa
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler sie haben
ja heute über die pflicht auch
gesprochen nun ist es ja so dass in dem
infektionsschutzgesetz das morgen
verabschiedet werden soll im bundestag
der 15 märz als termin für das
inkrafttreten der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht festgelegt wird ich würde
gerne wissen wie passt das zusammen mit
ihren plänen für die allgemeine
impfpflicht für dieses jahr an den kraft
treten zum zu anfang februar oder anfang
märz ins auge gefasst haben ist das noch
zu halten das ist ja sind ja eigentlich
frühere termine oder muster der zeitplan
gegebenenfalls noch angepasst werden und
auch an sie herr wüst und herr müller
die frage halten sie anfang februar oder
anfang märz die allgemeine impfpflicht
für realistisch
für die frage vielleicht ein hinweis das
gesetz tritt ziemlich schnell in kraft
auch diese regelung ich finde dass diese
woche beschlossen wird von bundestag und
bundesrat und der bundespräsident es
unterzeichnet hat und im
bundesgesetzblatt veröffentlicht hat
dann gilt es die frage die dort geregelt
ist
dann muss jemand den nachweis endgültig
führen und dann müssen wir da hat der
bundestag für seine beratung auch zu
grunde gelegt die erwägung das muss
jemand der jetzt nur eingestellt wird
und diese in pflichten erfüllen muss
wenn sie eintritt sich von jetzt bis
dahin noch impfen lassen können mit den
ganz
zeitabschnitten die wir für erste und
zweite impfung irgendwie hatte ich vor
schreiben und daraus ist dann in den
beratungen der fünfzehnte märz geworden
das hat also dann auch ein hinweis auf
die frage über die allgemeine
impfpflicht die ist ja nicht etwas das
dringend später kommen muss und da wird
sich diese frage auch stellen wie kann
jemand der sich an die pflicht halten
will und durch deswegen impfen lässt das
noch erfüllen und das wird man dann
rechnen müssen die beratung werden
sicherlich sehr schnell losgehen ich
weiß das nicht unter den abgeordneten
darüber schon diskutiert wird und der
bundesjustizminister hat heute noch mal
sehr ausdrücklich geschildert dass er
mit seinem ministerium für diese
gesetzgebung auch alle notwendigen
hilfen bereitstellen wird alles
wirtschaft anträge von abgeordneten
geben über die dann abgestimmt wird aber
die müssen natürlich von einem
ministerium als mit einer
formulierungshilfe vorbereiten und das
wetter machen
für mich sagen dass ich es nicht für
entscheidend welcher tag ist dann genau
ist der beschlussfassung oder der erste
tag der umsetzung sondern das für mich
wichtiger ist dass es seit wochen jetzt
diese öffentliche debatte und
kommunikation gibt zur impfpflicht und
das unzweifelhaft beschlossen und
festgelegt dass sie wird kommen und
insofern hat jeder jetzt die chance auch
natürlich die zeit zu nutzen sich noch
einmal auch inhaltlich damit
auseinanderzusetzen warum führen wir
diese debatte welche impfquote brauchen
wir auch um andere zu schützen und was
kann ich selbst dafür tun und wann kann
ich selbst welche impfung ja auch noch
in anspruch nehmen heute abend morgen
übermorgen an den weihnachtsfeiertagen
das ist das entscheidende glaube ich und
insofern müsste jedem klar sein dass es
uns sehr wichtig ist den
infektionsschutz den gesundheitsschutz
wirklich auf allen ebenen zur best so
gut wie möglich umzusetzen und dazu
gehört die impfpflicht kommen wird
also die frage ging ja auch an mich wenn
einem schema berücksichtigt wird ist es
glaube ich klug es gibt verschiedene
möglichkeiten sie impfen zu lassen gibt
auch schnelleres impfschema deswegen
waren wir etwas überrascht und hatten
dazu fragen weil ich schon der
überzeugung bin dass mitte märz
etwas anderes ist als im februar
insofern muss man sich das jetzt ganz
genau anschauen ob das jetzt wirklich
die schnellstmögliche variante ist aber
wir haben da ein gemeinsames interesse
die menschen dort zu schützen und ich
hoffe dass wir
dann nichts liegen lassen an zeit
als nächstes andreas rinke von reuters
der bundeskanzler ich hätte ganz gerne
nochmal nach dem expertengremium gefragt
dass sie erwähnt haben dass nächste
woche dann zum ersten mal haben soll nun
gibt es ja diese gremien auch auf länder
ebene ist ihre erwartungen dass die
bundesländer dann ihre gremien auflösen
also dass das das autoritative ist weil
es auf bundesebene ist und herr wüste da
sie ja zum beispiel in nrw auch so ein
gremium haben sehen sie dieses
bundesgremium was geschaffen wird
eigentlich dann als wegweisende an wenn
man entscheiden musste ob man weitere
maßnahmen verhängt
ich kann ihre frage kurz und knapp
beantworten nein das bedeutet nicht dass
die gremien in den ländern oder wo sonst
expertinnen und experten zusammenkommen
nicht mehr sich beraten soll mehr
vorschläge machen sondern es geht
einfach darum dass wir für die deutsche
politik an der beratung haben und der
unterschied soll eben sein dass wir
nicht nur eine diskussion unter den
wissenschaftlern und wissenschaftlern
verfolgen können sondern dass dort auch
ein möglicher konsens formuliert wird er
uns dann berät bei den entscheidungen
die wir die demokratisch legitimierten
treffen müssen und das bleibt für die
bundesebene der bundestag und die
bundesregierung dass sie sind den
ländern die landtage und die
landesregierung und das wird sich auch
nicht ändern aber es wird jetzt
gewissermaßen dadurch meine beratung zu
stande gebracht die uns zum beispiel
auch hilft mit den neuen entwicklung
durch die virus imitation umzugehen sie
stück für stunden zu bewerten und den
moment nicht zu verpassen wo wir
konsequent sofort etwas machen müssen
weil wir neue einsichten haben
die menschen so gut wie möglich zu
schützen erfordert in dieser dynamischen
lage dass man eigene erkenntnisse aus
ständig auf die neuesten stand bringt
insofern wäre es glaube ich nicht klug
wenn die landesregierung auf die
gewinnung eigener erkenntnisse durch
beratung verzichten würden
dann hab ich als nächstes cerstin
gammelin von der süddeutschen zeitung
herr bundeskanzler sie haben heute das
erste mal regie geführt und die
verantwortung getragen bei einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wie anders
wurde hat sich das anders für sie
angefühlt und noch eine nachfrage zu
ihrem gesundheitsminister da hat ja naht
impfen wenn impfstoff inventur
angekündigt bedeutet dass das nicht
genug impfstoff da ist oder dass man
nicht genau weiß wo er ist
ich bin mir in dieser
konferenz aus in mit verschiedenen
aufgaben beauftragt schon lange dabei
als
zweimal als bundesminister ganz lange
als regierungschef eines der länder und
jetzt eben als bundeskanzler
ich glaube das hilft mir die
perspektiven zu verstehen aber so ganz
anders ist nicht ich habe mich aber
gefreut dass es nun ausgerechnet zum
auftakt
konstruktive freundliche beratung waren
die mich im übrigen unabhängig von mir
und dem ersten mal auch so
gefreut haben weil das ja jetzt genau
das ist was die bürger bürger von uns
erwarten dass wir uns unterhaken und
dass wir gemeinsam vorgehen das bin ich
sicher wird uns jetzt gelingen das auch
eine gute botschaft ist das zweite ist
wir
haben wir den krisenstab eingerichtet
der gesundheitsminister ist da dran um
zu identifizieren ob wir genug impfstoff
haben wurde im schloss sieben einzeln
befindet und wir wollen das nicht nur
auf dieses jahr beziehen wo wir sehr
konkret damit beschäftigen und natürlich
auch die weiteren perspektiven
betrachten denn das ist ja die grundlage
für alles was wir jetzt machen das ist
hart der arbeit das konkret hinzukriegen
und ist auch nicht zu ende ist wird was
auch weitergehen und
trotzdem kann man sagen wenn das was
sich bisher ab zeichnet sich auch bei
jeder noch so tief in betrachtung wieder
bestätigt dann werden wir das ehrgeizige
ziel das wir für dieses jahr haben auch
mit genügend impfstoff erreichen können
und dass das ja eine gute botschaft es
lohnt sich nämlich weiterzumachen mit
der eröffnung von neuen impfzentren in
den kommunen in den kreisen in
deutschland war mit mobilen teams mit
den verstärkten impf angeboten die die
ärzten und ärzte machen und natürlich
auch den künftigen weiteren im
berechtigten
eine beratung befindliche gesetz
geschaffen werden also zb apothekerinnen
und apothekern und das finde ich es eine
ganz ganz gute entwicklung die man dann
auch mit sich nehmen kann aber wir
werden dranbleiben und das wird eine
dauerhafte aufgabe sein denn auch das
kann man jetzt für das schlussfolgerung
aus dem was wir heute wissen mitnehmen
erstens wir werden wohl noch länger
impfen müssen
und deshalb macht es sinn dass die im
strukturen die wir jetzt neu
installieren nicht so schnell wieder
herunter gefahren werden sondern dass
wir das mit einer längeren perspektive
versehen und vielleicht ist es jetzt
tatsächlich so dass wir uns darauf
einrichten müssen dass wir irgendwann
mal wieder uns einen pitch beschaffen
müssen damit wir gut genug geschützt
sind und auch das spricht dafür jetzt
weiter zu machen und ganz engagiert
daran zu arbeiten und zweitens wir
müssen gucken dass wir genug bestellen
stellt haben für die nächste zeit im
nächsten jahr und das ist die arbeit der
minister und krisenstab und general
breuer jetzt in engem einvernehmen und
organisieren
dann habe ich als nächstes rosalia um
man ja von der deutschen welle
ich vermute das ganze sie haben wir
haben ihn zwei wochen weihnachten haben
sie heute auch darüber gesprochen so
welches risiko das bedeutet ist der
reisezeit familienzeit für die
ausbreitung von omikron im anschluss und
kurze nachfrage noch einmal oder frage
zu morgen sie sind ja in paris heute hat
frau berbalk demnächst neue
außenministerin sich klar positioniert
sie hat die play französischen pläne
abgelehnt atomkraft als grüne energie
anzusehen werden sie morgen das mit
gleicher härte vertreten
was das letzte betrifft ist wir treffen
uns um eine gemeinsame strategie mit
frankreich zu entwickeln dass es der
geist aus dem heraus kooperation
entsteht und daran arbeiten wir ganz
hart das wird nicht nur morgen so sein
sondern auch noch ganz ganz lange zeit
immer wieder bei allen themen die
anstehenden auch bei diesen die position
die
entwickelt worden sind um die
herausforderung des klimawandels in den
ländern zu bewältigen sind
unterschiedlich überall in der welt und
es geht ja darum daraus eine kraft zu
schaffen die es möglich macht jeweils
unterschiedlich auf das gleiche ziel zu
marschieren aber gleichzeitig auch etwas
zu schaffen auch dass man sich
miteinander verständigen kann das glaube
ich es möglich wenn es auch nicht leicht
ist aber wir wollen ja die gute
kooperation
mal sehen
und
ansonsten das war die erste ja das ist
in der tat ein großes thema
wir haben jetzt sehr weitreichende
einschränkung gemacht dass kontakte von
und kämpften betrifft das wird jetzt
gerade überall umgesetzt und wird sogar
und wird auch weiter wird müssen das
gilt dann ja auch über die
weihnachtstage und wer das neue jahr wir
haben schon jetzt beschlossen dass wir
um die durch die vielen kurven patienten
auf den intensivstationen schon
herausgeforderten krankenhäuser nicht zu
überlasten
silvester oh ja nicht die das übliche
dollar spektakel haben und dass es
schwer für die industrie dass verbände
dort auch sorge dafür tragen dass die
das wirtschaftlich bestehen können aber
es ist eine entscheidung wegen der
krankenhäuser und das zeigt ja dass die
lage ernst ist und deshalb auch diese
maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben
richtig sind wir werden wir haben
kontakt beschränkungen für
öffentliche
veranstaltung der zahl und auch kontakt
beschränkungen miteinander besprochen
was das treffen von sehr wohl geimpften
der im privaten bereich betrifft die
sind großzügiger als die ungeimpften das
werden sie auch bleiben und da gucken
wir natürlich ob die uns auch
weiterhelfen durch diese zeit aber das
ist etwas was wir genau beurteilen
können wenn wir mehr wissen als wir das
heute wissen deshalb die verabredung
alles genau zu erforschen und stellten
zügig zu entscheiden
habe ich als nächstes christina
schweizer von sie
dann noch mal nachgehakt auch bei den
ministerpräsidenten
stephan weil hat ja eine weihnachtsruhe
vorgeschlagen
teilen sie diese einschätzung dass man
da auch noch mal stärkere kontakt
beschränkungen machen muss und er stolz
sein sie die frage gegen hass und hetze
vorzugehen jetzt sind sie als
bundeskanzler auch einer der alle
deutschen auch miteinander verbinden
soll und will die frage droht eine
spaltung der gesellschaft und wie kann
man diese jähnigen mit einbinden die
jetzt nicht bei fackel märschen
mitlaufen aber dennoch sich es erweise
entfremdet haben in der korona pandemie
glaube die erste frage war nochmal an
die ministerpräsidenten gericht in der
wüste will ich kann das kann man es
gerne beantworten wir haben uns
verabredet zu agieren und wieder
zusammenzukommen wenn der rat der
experten in der nächsten woche
insbesondere zu einer vertiefte
einschätzung in sachen omikron kommt und
dies erfordert aber auch der krisenstab
unter umständen dinge von uns verlangt
gemeinsam zu machen
das war sozusagen die entsprechung auf
die idee über
weihnachten noch was zu machen nächste
woche erkenntnisgewinn und wenn nötig
dann zu agieren
dort wo es nötig ist kann man in den
ländern auch handeln und es wird auch
gehandelt einschränkungen gibt es ja
auch schon wir sehen das auch in unserem
nachbar bundesland in brandenburg dass
da auch natürlich sofort reagiert wird
will aber auch noch mal sagen dass es
nicht nötig ist sich zu weihnachten
einzugraben man kann die familie und
freunde treffen das kommt darauf an wie
und wir haben alle seit monaten darauf
aufmerksam gemacht das ist eben nicht
klug ist mit 20 oder mehr menschen
zusammen zu kommen und zu feiern ohne
auf den entsprechenden schutz zu achten
ohne darauf zu achten mit wem man feiert
wer wie geschützt es deswegen gab es ja
auch schon die verabredung zu dem thema
der ungeimpften und das werde ich immer
wieder vermitteln wenn wir besonnen sind
wenn wir uns und andere schützen sind
dinge auch möglich auch sicher möglich
und auch über die weihnachtsfeiertage
also insofern eine allgemeine kontakt
beschränkung hat heute so wie sie es
vielleicht meinen keine rolle gespielt
und herr wüst hat völlig recht darauf
hingewiesen dass ihr natürlich immer
sofort reagieren und auch zusammenkommen
können wenn es erforderlich wird und
wenn es neue erkenntnisse gibt und das
haben wir heute auch miteinander so
festgehalten
deutschland ist nicht gespalten das
gefällt mir nicht dass eine solche
diskussion in diesem land stattfindet
die überwiegende mehrheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger hat sich impfen
lassen sehr sehr viele das was uns jetzt
umtreibt ist dass es sehr sehr viele
sind aber nicht genug um zu verhindern
dass von den ungeimpften nicht das
infektionsgeschehen wieder neu so stark
zu ausgeht dass die intensivstationen
unserer krankenhäuser
sehr herausgefordert sind mit sehr
vielen patienten die sie unterstützen
müssen damit die ihr leben verteidigen
können und das ist ja das wollen wir all
diese maßnahmen ergreifen und auch warum
wir darüber diskutieren dass es ein
richtig mitgezogen eine impfpflicht gibt
und warum wir darüber uns verständigt
haben am politischen prozess auf den weg
zu bringen bei dem es um eine allgemeine
impfpflicht geht aber ich fühle mich
auch als regierungschef als kanzler
derjenigen die skeptisch sind oder
bisher nicht dazu gekommen sind oder
noch nicht überzeugt waren dass sie sich
impfen lassen und versuchen natürlich
indem ich eine klare haltung einnehme zu
sagen bitte lasst euch impfen das ist
gut für ihre gesundheit für die eurer
liebsten für alle die ihnen die kennt
und auch für uns alle denn wir sind dann
haben wir ja auch solidarität schuldig
damit wir eine gute zukunft haben
das ist eine diskussion die man führen
kann und muss und die man auch streitig
führen kann das gehört zur demokratie
dazu im conti hast ja nicht dass alle
einer meinung sein müssen aber sie
bedeutet in diesem fall wo das ja jedem
wird auch dass wir da nicht weglaufen
denn es geht hier ja um die gesundheit
von uns allen durch eine virusinfektion
die uns bedrohen global in europa auch
in deutschland und es geht umgekehrt
darum dass wir natürlich auch wissen
dass wenn wir uns impfen lassen das
natürlich an vorletzter uns selbst jeden
einzelnen von uns jede einzelne kürzung
eigenen körper berührt dass man da
verschiedene meinungen haben kann das
ist jetzt erstmal nicht weiter
verwunderlich und darf auch niemand
aufgeregt
aufregend ist das aber was nicht geht es
wenn in dieser diskussion einige sehr
sehr wenige
nötigen
drohend werden mit fackel aufmärschen
vor privaten häusern und wohnungen das
kann nicht das darf nicht und das wird
nicht akzeptiert werden da sind wir uns
als demokraten demokraten alle einig
aber da muss man auch diejenigen die
skeptisch sind was das impfen betrifft
eher schutz nehmen nur weil einige von
diesen sich so verhalten gilt das ja für
die anderen nicht und die möchte ich
dann doch noch überzeugen
vorletzte frage markus decker
aktionsnetzwerk deutschland
bundeskanzler was die allgemeine
impfpflicht angeht die müsste ja
basieren darauf auf der information wer
eigentlich geimpft ist und wer nicht in
diesem kontext hat der deutsche
städtetag heute ein im register ins ins
gespräch gebracht
wollen sie so etwas ist das möglich auch
kurzfristig oder denken sie an andere
lösungen und noch eine zweite frage so
weit wir wissen haben sie auch heute
über das thema flüchtlingspolitik
gesprochen das war aber heute auf der
pressekonferenz bisher kein thema haben
sie darüber nicht gesprochen oder oder
können sie dazu noch etwas sagen
zunächst einmal
geht es darum dass wir den politischen
entscheidungsprozess voranbringen der
eine an dessen ende eine allgemeine
impfpflicht steht
und das
geschieht jetzt
natürlich wird in dem zusammenhang
darüber diskutiert werden wie man das am
besten
bewältigen kann
ob man dazu ein impf register braucht
weiß ich nicht ich bin da sehr skeptisch
es gibt auch andere wege die pflicht
gilt ja erst mal als gesetzliche regeln
und dann haben wir alle möglichkeiten
wie bei allen anderen das wozu wir
verpflichtet sind und wozu die gesetze
und sahen halten das auch zu
kontrollieren und nacht zu halten also
da bin ich nicht so sicher ob das jetzt
der richtige
weg dazu ist aber da will ich der
diskussion auch im parlament nicht
vorgreifen aber eine vorsichtige skepsis
schon formulieren
was die frage betrifft der
situation der
flucht migration und da ist ja jetzt in
diesem fall insbesondere die gemeint die
über belarus stattfindet haben wir
darüber gesprochen das ist ja auch
richtig angesichts der gegenwärtigen
lage und haben uns einfach nochmal die
lage angeschaut wie sie jetzt ist es ist
ganz klar
der diktator in belarus anders kann man
den ja nicht nennen hat er keine
legitimation von seiten seiner
bevölkerung hat mit hilfe von
flüchtlingen versucht druck auszuüben
und viele viele eingeladen zu kommen
dass es mittlerweile weitgehend
unterbunden weil die europäische union
und auch deutschland sehr viel druck
gemacht haben und klare hinweise gegeben
haben in hinblick auf fluggesellschaften
hingegen auf flughäfen wir haben noch
mit vielen ländern aus denen die
abweisen nach belarus stattgefunden
gesprochen und man sieht richtig dass
das
zurückgegangen ist das sehen wir was ja
auch gut ist dass es eine
rückwärtsbewegung gibt also viele
derjenigen die nach bill ausgekommen
sind auch wieder ausreisen und drittens
wissen wir dass insbesondere
internationale flüchtlingshilfe
organisationen hilfe anbieten
insbesondere jenseits der grenze und das
ist etwas was wir natürlich unterstützen
und es geht ja auch um die unmittelbare
not wenn man irgendwo in am kalten markt
ist muss unterstützung geleistet werden
und
das ist die lage
dann habe ich als allerletzte fragerin
birgit ihren von bloomberg
herr scholz sie sagten dass weihnachten
ein großes thema ist wurde denn auch
schon diskutiert eventuell wieder die
regelungen vom vergangenen jahr zu
weisen einzuführen also ähnliche kontakt
beschränkungen und wie war dazu das
meinungsbild und dann auch noch zum
thema impfstoff ist dann auch vielleicht
noch mal das war ja auch in der
vergangenheit immer schon mal das thema
das man sputnik letztendlich auf
nationaler ebene zulässt ist das auch
besprochen worden
also was das letzte thema betrifft das
ja eine sache des unternehmens das
diesen impfstoff produziert dass sich um
ein europäisches zulassungsverfahren
bemühen was es tut und es auch
vorantreiben muss in dem die notwendigen
daten geliefert
und der prozess der daten ab lieferung
ist noch nicht abgeschlossen
das ist die lage die jeder kennt da kann
man ja nicht zwischen gehen und sagen
werden gucken uns keine daten werden wir
lassen einfach so zu das ist ja nicht
richtig und
es ist müßig darüber zu spekulieren
warum es nicht die
notwendigen informationen gibt aber am
ende ist das ja ein verfahren in dem das
alles bewertet werden muss aber
ist keine vorbehalte und wir sind auch
sehr offen und freuen uns wenn das eine
zulassung gibt unter dafür zuständigen
behörde
was die
frage betrifft wie das über weihnachten
weiter geht haben mir herr wüst und der
müller schon gesagt
und noch mal unterstrichen was ich auch
ausgeführt habe wir gucken uns jetzt
genau die daten an wir versuchen alle
wissenschaftliche expertise zu holen
hinblick auf das was an veränderungen
möglicherweise durch mutationen
stattfindet und was das für konsequenzen
für uns hat dazu holen wir uns auch den
notwendigen rat sehen uns die
entwicklung der infektionszahlen hat
sehen uns an wie die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben wirken und ob sie so
wird man ob sie ausreichend sondern
werden notfalls kurzfristig neue weitere
diskussionen und entscheidungen auf der
tagesordnung stehen
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen für ihr
interesse und gedanken ich zwar ein
bundeskanzler dem regierenden
bürgermeister und den
ministerpräsidenten
zahlen kommt nach hause und das bald
ja und da sind wir wieder so weit also
die pressekonferenz nach den ersten bund
länder beratungen unter der leitung des
neuen bundeskanzlers olaf scholz ich
weiß noch mal kurz zusammen scholz sagte
also die ersten beratungen unter seiner
führung waren sehr konstruktiv es war
ein sehr guter auftakt das haben die
anderen beiden redner auch bestätigt es
ging natürlich in erster linie um die
frage wie es weitergeht mit corona da
muss dringend gewusst hat werden am ziel
30 millionen menschen bis jahresende
nochmal zu impfen erst- zweit- oder eben
dritte impfung hält olaf scholz fest der
krisenstab soll in der kommenden woche
sich dann auch noch mal zusammen setzen
und dort auch seine empfehlungen
aussprechen es ging auch um die neuen
maßnahmen gegen hass und hetze im netz
verschwörungstheorien in messenger
diensten und zu diesen und anderen
fragen die gerade auch noch aufgeworfen
wurden werden wir gleich noch mal
sprechen mit unserer kollegin nicole
diekmann und an euch auch noch mal die
anregung uns eure fragen und kommentare
mitzuteilen und jetzt hoffe ich dass
nicole uns zugeschaltet ist und da sehe
ich sie auch wunderbar nicole also wir
haben gerade schon ein paar sachen
angerissen die dort thematisiert worden
sind was ist dein fazit was ist dir
aufgefallen in dieser pressekonferenz na
ja also es war das ist ja gerade eben
auch schon gesagt die erste
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz unter einem
frisch gewählten bundeskanzler olaf
scholz der saß jetzt nicht zum ersten
mal in dieser runde hat er auch gerade
nochmal gesagt in verschiedenen
funktionen zuletzt als vizekanzler als
bundesfinanzminister hat er daran schon
teilgenommen aber es ist natürlich auch
ein symbolisch wichtiger termin das war
jetzt dieses erste mal für olaf scholz
da saß er nun dass es ein neues bild da
saßen jetzt nur männer angela merkel ist
nicht mehr dabei neben scheut saßen da
der vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hendrik
wüst und sein stellvertreter michael
müller regierender bürgermeister in
berlin was den dreien wichtig war du
hast es auch gerade gesagt war ein bild
der einheit zu bieten und auch ein bild
zu bieten von wir haben die rufe
verstanden das hat olaf scholz gerade
auch noch mal gesagt sobald wir vom
expertenrat
aus anderer richtung die die marschroute
beziehungsweise hinweise darauf erhalten
dass sich die lage verändert kommen wir
jedes mal schnell zusammen wir wissen
wir müssen schnell handeln es gab ja in
den vergangenen wochen bevor die ampel
überhaupt in ihre ämter kam das
komplette neue kabinett wehr schon
kritik man sei zu zögerlich sowohl im
zeitplan als auch mit den maßnahmen
dieser eindruck dass man jetzt schnell
handelt dass man entschlossen handelt
und dass man im geiste handelt zu wissen
wie dramatisch die lage ist in sachen
corona der hatte an einer stelle einen
kleinen bruch und da ging es um das
thema einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
da geht es darum dass leute die in
altenheim im pflegeheim in
krankenhäusern und so weiter arbeiten
also mit den sogenannten
besonders wohlhabenden gruppen also mit
menschen jeden tag zu tun haben die sehr
anfällig sind für eine infektion und bei
denen eine infektion mit corona zu einem
schlimmen verlauf so gab es sogar zum
tode führen könnten dass die geimpft
sein müssen vergangene woche gab es
schon eine mpk das war am zweiten also
vor genau einer woche nach dieser mpk
gab es wie immer anschließend ein
beschlusspapier und darin stand dass
etwa ab/bis ab februar
2022 diese einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht gelten solle nun gibt es
morgen die zweite und dritte lesung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
das für genau diese sache einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht zuständig ist und
auch anschließend ebenfalls eine
sondersitzung es geht jetzt hobby
galotti im bundesrat da soll dieses
gesetz dann verabschiedet werden darin
steht jetzt nicht mehr februar
2022 sondern märz 2022
und da sagte hendrik wüst
nrw-ministerpräsident und anders als
olaf scholz und michael müller die da
eben mit saßen nicht spd politiker
sondern sie politiker da sagte er da sei
man überrascht gewesen und da hätte man
fragen gehabt und dann ich habe mir das
extra aufgeschrieben sagte sagte er ich
hoffe dass wir da nichts liegen lassen
an zahlt das zeigt das könnte ein grund
dafür gewesen sein dass diese
pressekonferenz doch länger gedauert hat
als zuvor gedacht denn das war
tatsächlich der einzige punkt an dem ich
dachte okay also da war man sich nicht
hundertprozentig einig da gibt es kritik
dass hätte man sich anscheinend von cdu
seite von unionsseite
das wurde jetzt eben klar schneller
gewünscht also mal sehen ob da noch
konfliktpotenzial drin liegt ja in der
tat das ist eine spannende frage wir
haben ja uns auch die frage gestellt
überschrift unsere sendung reichen die
korona maßnahmen aus was war jetzt so
dein eindruck im großen und ganzen haben
doch die protagonisten eigentlich gesagt
also das was auf dem tisch liegt wäre
jetzt erstmal in ordnung das wird jetzt
sicher angeschaut oder hattest du das
gefühl dass da noch mal dringend jetzt
weiter nachjustiert werden muss mit
ausnahme jetzt des aspekts
demokratischen angesprochen hast was die
impfpflicht angeht na ja das wäre jetzt
zu früh wir haben ja jetzt wenn man sehr
sehr viel gelernt in den letzten 20
monaten unter anderem das instanzen oder
dass die inzidenz immer so einen zum
bild abgeben von dem was vor 14 tagen
quasi passiert ist beziehungsweise dass
es sich um 14 tage verzögert
vergangenen donnerstag heute vor einer
woche gab es die mpk wo ja weitreichende
beschlüsse gefällt worden sind das war
eine außerordentliche mpk heute die war
sowieso schon lange angesetzt das heißt
erst tage später wurden diese beschlüsse
umgesetzt in den ländern es ist jetzt
noch zu früh an den zahlen seriös
ablesen zu können ob die ja tatsächlich
leicht sinkende inzidenz
zurückzuführen ist auch diese beschlüsse
oder ob die zahlen zum teil auch daran
liegen dass die gesundheitsämter die
theorie gibt es ja auch vielerorts
überlastet sind und deshalb nicht mehr
richtig nach melden können also sprich
das ist jetzt noch zu früh zu sagen und
auch da klang bei hendrik wüst cdu
ministerpräsident nrw etwas an der sagte
nämlich gestern der sagte nämlich gerade
gestern im hauptausschuss
solange die ausschüsse im bundestag die
einzelnen ressorts noch nicht noch nicht
konstituiert sind gibt es einen
hauptausschuss der hat gestern zusammen
gesessen und da ging es eben auch noch
mal um die beschlüsse und er sagt da sei
angeklungen von experten die da wohl
gehört worden sein
dass diese beschlüsse womöglich noch
nicht reichen und was wir jetzt eben
auch in der pressekonferenz erfahren
haben ist nächste woche
gibt es eine anhörung gibt es ein
treffen mit der expertenkommission
da wird auch noch mal beraten und dann
sollen auch nochmal ministerpräsidenten
bund und länder zusammenkommen und mit
blick auf weihnachten beraten denn es
wird eine idee vom niedersächsischen
ministerpräsidenten weil der so etwas
wie eine weihnachtsruhe vorgeschlagen
hat wir erinnern uns es gab mal anfang
dieses jahres
die idee einer oster ruhe an der
sogenannten größere quasi ein als loch
downs rund um ostern so schnell konnte
man gucken wie diese idee wieder
kassiert worden ist da hat sich angela
merkel da war sie dann noch
bundeskanzlerin in bemerkenswerter art
und weise vor der regierung gestellt und
das auf ihre kappe genommen und offen
davon gesprochen
diese debatte sei ein fehler gewesen
jetzt gibt es also eine ähnliche idee da
kann man mal sehr gespannt sein wie es
damit weitergeht in der tat darf man
sehr gespannt sein gerade was
weihnachten natürlich angeht das immer
ein ganz neues thema was unsere
userinnen und user natürlich auch immer
sehr interessiert in ears alte jogger
fragt uns über youtube warum gibt es
noch keine impfpflicht du hast vorhin
das thema angesprochen fühlt sich so an
als fürchtete man sich vor den
impfgegnern kann man das so pauschal
sagen
ich weiß nicht ob es nur die impfgegner
sind die frage finde ich die
sicherstellt ist hätte man die debatte
über eine impfpflicht schon früher
geführt wenn es in diesem jahr keine
bundestagswahl gegeben hätte ich würde
mal sagen dass die frage nach einer
impfpflicht noch mal eine andere liga
ist als die frage ob man sich generell
impfen lässt oder nicht also das greift
natürlich nochmal viel tiefer in
grundrechte ein recht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit
wir haben das ja letzte woche hier auch
in der sendung schon mal sehr intensiv
diskutiert saar attacke weil er da
unsere rechtsexperten und hat das sehr
anschaulich ausgeführt also das ist noch
mal eine andere frage aber natürlich
gibt es die sorge dass das hitzige
debatten gibt ja und es gibt halt auch
das kommunikative problem das
auch die regierungsparteien die jetzt an
der macht sind
kategorisch eine impfpflicht
ausgeschlossen haben zu großen teilen
und der weg dahin jetzt zu erklären
warum man nun doch über eine impfpflicht
spricht der ist argumentativ zwar schon
zu bauen aber das braucht eben auch
seine zeit weil man sorge hat nicht nur
vor den impfgegnern sondern generell
dass ankündigungen die man macht und die
man dann zurück nimmt auch vertrauen in
der mitte der gesellschaft brocken lässt
die politik bestimmt natürlich also das
kann man nachvollziehen das war mit
sicherheit auch und ich glaube das geben
die meisten politischen akteure
inzwischen auch zu vielleicht nicht so
klug das kategorisch so früher
auszuschließen denn man konnte einfach
die entwicklung noch nicht richtig
absehen und jetzt steht man nur mal vor
dem problem das ist jetzt mit einer
impfpflicht offenbar dann doch
wesentlich besser funktioniert bzw dann
nur eventuell so funktionieren kann weil
der anteil eben der ungeimpften noch
immer zu groß ist und darauf muss man
jetzt natürlich reagieren aber ich
verstehe schon dass kommunikative
dilemma weil wir vielleicht noch über
einen aspekt sprechen der auch
tatsächlich doch einigen raum
eingenommen hat in dieser
pressekonferenz es gibt gemeinsame
maßnahmen gegen hass und hetze die soll
es jedenfalls geben im netz was soll da
genau geschehen was haben die
protagonisten dazu gesagt es geht um
messenger dienst
ist eben nicht ausgesprochen worden aber
es geht um telegramm telegram ist ein
ich habs grad schon gesagt am
messenger-dienst ähnlich wie whatsapp
telegramm lässt aber viel mehr menschen
in gruppen zu es geht um die sogenannten
öffentlichen gruppen aufteilen im
prinzip funktioniert das wie eine
facebook seite ich kann eine gruppe
gründen bei tele bärn und kann dort
inhalte posten und bis zu 200.000 leute
können meinen kanal bei telegramm
abonnieren das ist eine ganze ganze
menge so und telegramm
damit die macher von telegram von denen
niemand so richtig weiß wo sie
eigentlich sitzen das ist eine relativ
dubiose angelegenheit
die werben damit dass sie mit
strafverfolgungsbehörden nicht
zusammenarbeiten wir wissen auch bei
facebook und bei twitter und bei anderen
ist der luft nach oben telegramm aber
wirkt explizit damit dass sie keine
daten weitergeben das zieht natürlich
ein gewisses klientel an unter anderem
da sind holocaust leugnungen was hier
verboten ist es ist ein straftatbestand
volksverhetzung das wetter offen
ausgelebt so und
telegramm spielt im moment konkret
deshalb bei uns in der öffentlichen
debatte eine rolle weil anscheinend der
fackel aufmarsch vor dem privathaus der
sächsischen gesundheitsministerin am
vergangenen wochenende organisiert wurde
auch über telegramm gruppen oder eine
talibangruppe weil dort morddrohungen
gegen den sächsischen
ministerpräsidenten kretzschmar
nachzulesen sind beziehungsweise auch
mordpläne nun will man telegram in das
so genannte netzwerk durchsetzungs
gesetz mit einbeziehen kurz netz dg das
ist ein 2017 voll in kraft und nimmt
auch die plattformen also ich habe es
eben schon gesagt facebook twitter
versucht es an die kandare zu nehmen das
ziel ist hass und hetze im netz und auch
desinformation das ist ja auch ganz
wichtig gerade während der korona
pandemie dem einheit zu gebieten so und
das ist jetzt eben sehr auftrag der
länder an den bund vor allem an den
frisch gewählten frisch ernannten
justizminister marco buschmann von der
fdp sich darum zu kümmern ja also das
auch noch ein ganz wichtiger punkt in
diesen beratungen heute die sich
natürlich in erster linie um corona
gedreht haben nicole ganz lieben dank
dafür dass du so lange bei uns geblieben
bist und mit uns nochmal die
veräußerungen dieser drei herren
eingeordnet hast einen schönen abend
wünsche ich dir nach belieben dankeschön
wie gesagt für das intensive und
informative vor allem gespräch auch
nochmal ganz herzlichen dank an unsere
userinnen und user für die zahlreichen
zuschriften fragen und kommentare und ja
wir haben eigentlich jetzt nichts weiter
zu tun als euch einen schönen abend zu
wünschen noch mal danke zu sagen und bis
zum nächsten mal